It's 12.30.
Good morning, everybody.
I'm still waking up, guys.
I don't know why I'm playing Cassidy right now.
I'm not even going to be playing DPS.
Guys, I'm sorry.
I'm still...
My brain is still...
waking up I can never do 1230 streams because my brain is
always waking up I don't even know if the sound volume's
okay is my sound guy here is he here all right let me make
sure my sound is like not too loud all right let's see all
right look at this like gold gun okay guys i might have like
clickbaited you guys because i'm okay to be fair it is
master's rank but it doesn't mean this account is masters it
just means that i i will get i'll definitely get into master
games i just this account might not be masters but the
player base is not as high as it once was that like there is
a potential that i'll get into masters games um because one
one i found out i found out that like uh not today like
recently that like uh masters five is uh also i don't know
if it's too loud can't tell masters five is the threshold
for support to hit top 500 and i heard a lot of players are
like sort of low-key hard-stuck masters at the moment which
is very surprising like i was looking at streams and a lot
of players are like in masters like a lot of like the good
players i used to know back then are like in the masters elo
at the moment i was like what the fuck
i was like damn okay and um and then and then so i was like
oh wait i'm gonna be griefing top 500 players oh okay wait
because i was like okay i do have an account that has but
like obviously i'm not going to be playing on that account
because um i used to be good hence the word hence the past
tense but now i've been playing like other games like bunny
garden and like that so
so like i don't know how how like bunny garden and flight
simulator so like i don't know how well that translates back
to overwatch these days so i was just like um so so i was
like okay maybe i shouldn't play on the grandmaster account
i was like all right maybe i should do something that has a
master's mmar at first i was like all right i'm just gonna
rank up this account to masters and just go from there but
this is my main account by the way i haven't touched this
main i haven't
years with rank so because of that they had a hard reset in
rank um from over they had a hard reset from like overwatch
one to overwatch two um i mean like it's not like super okay
maybe not hard reset a soft reset uh so like i did
placements on this account and then um i did placements on
this account and then I did uh I uh yes this is the
Overwatch 1 account so like this this is actually this is
actually like the main main account and I was like usually
in the past I'll be like oh I don't want to tape this
account because uh this account is so sacred it has like you
know it has these it has all of these sprays you know oh my
god look at that you can tell it's the main account Oh, the
sprays are animated.
Whoa.
Holy shit.
Look at that.
The sprays, they move.
So for those who are not familiar with the Overwatch rating
system, the spray moves because I was top 500, so you get a
moving spray.
So I was like, usually in the past...
past Tokyo be like no don't taint this account because
because that's your top 500 account don't play on it but
like all my top 500 records have been fucking erased because
they erased Overwatch 1 top 500 leaderboards so it doesn't
matter anymore it doesn't matter anymore I don't I don't
care I didn't get top 500 in Overwatch 2 on this account I
did it on a I did it on a brand new account.
So, like, this account doesn't have the Overwatch 2 Top 500.
So, it doesn't matter to me.
Plastic, thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
Are you uploading to Flats right now?
What's the Flats right now?
I don't watch, I don't watch Flats.
I'm sorry.
Thank you for the magenta soup.
Thank you, thank you.
He used to cry in Overwatch Rank.
I bumped into him a lot in Overwatch Rank.
But I don't watch his YouTube content.
Because his YouTube content.
He's like.
Like.
What are the reasons?
The Plants is really good at gaming the algorithm.
And like.
Making videos that like.
Majority of the Overwatch players like to watch.
But like.
I'm not majority of the Overwatch players.
I just watch Rank.
Like I don't care.
I would, right, and also, like, these days, I don't even
really watch Overwatch Rink streams.
And I only watch, like, I only watch, like, Shure 4 playing
Rink, because I think it's funny when he loses.
I'm not, like, other girls.
I just watch Shure 4 play Overwatch Rink, because I just
think it's funny.
And I guess, like, Ruben, too, sometimes.
Because he's a friend.
I don't think sound guy's awake guys sound guy is not as
awake as me so how has the how how has the sound been uh
chat yeah I think that's like the only Overwatch content
I've been watching the last couple of months like it's
literally just sure for it mostly um I'm like trying to
think have I watched anybody else I mean I watched like like
I guess like 10 like five minutes of Aspen meta i was like
she's a support player like i was like i was like all right
let's see what's meta okay i need i need to know what
support meta is and now i was just like all right aspen's
the support player is the best way to figure it out watch
the watch the support player to see what meta is call that
uh but i haven't like actually watched overwatch content i
think like by the time flats became an overwatch content
creator i've stopped watching overwatch because i used to
watch of watch content but like i like but that was like
past doki very very past doki also you might be like oh my
god doki why is your name on the left side kitsune um they
have like a streamer mode now where your name changes every
game thank fucking god for that because that actually is a
lifesaver because like uh i i was like a little bit
embarrassed Okay, no, okay, this is also the reason why I
stopped caring about, like, my rank on this account,
because, like, there's streamer mode now, so then I was just
like, and it changes every game, so every game, um, your
name changes on the bottom left, which is a fucking
lifesaver, especially if I have private profile, so they'll
never know, that's me, uh, but, like, I was a little
embarrassed in Diamond Yilo, I was, I was a little, I was a
little embarrassed being just a little bit embarrassed being
in diamond elo on this account so I had I was like oh they
must never know they must never know um no way you're
actually good in video game I was good in video games we
don't know anymore
anymore all right um let me ask like an oh wait is my are
any of my mods on that's a good question wait are any of my
mods on what do you mean it was okay there's a reason why
i'm on streamer mode i am a bit embarrassed also like uh
ruben asked if we wanted to do i'm gonna play a couple of
solo games first and then if i if i d rank because i'm
actually like on the line between diamond one and diamond
two so like if we i won't join voice though i won't join
voice call but if we d rank we're calling in reinforcements
which is like so we have like three games at least of solo
we have three games of solo at least okay
so so that'll be it we're gonna try our best so yeah anyway
we're gonna be queuing support d1 support and then if we get
to masters then yippee uh but anyway you're gonna see what i
mean regardless of what rank i am at the moment because i'm
in d1 i will automatically get not automatically but
majority of time i'll be in master games so like in the end
i will throw i will fucking get somebody out of top 500 if
it's and that's all that matters chat that's all that
matters we're not playing cassidy i just like i just like
warming up in uh like i just like the sound and hitting the
headshots in uh in the training range on cassidy because
it's not as fun on any other character it's only on it's
only fun on cassidy um all right let's see i think my i have
like a backup sound guy right uh all right all right i have
a backup sound guy so i'm gonna check also like next week by
the way guys next week uh i tweeted about it but next week i
said next week like five times uh i know i said that we're
gonna have a rest week but like it might not end up being a
rest week because there's a lot of stuff going on next week
There's a You'll find out when the schedule Fucking drops
because I'm so I'm still like figuring stuff out But you
guys will see When the When the schedule drops and then
you'll see why You'll see You'll see why Alright Oh my god
Why do I hear myself?
Do I have a stream up?
my god where's the stream oh okay sorry sorry guys i had a i
had my own stream open and i was like what the fuck who is
that bitch that voices okay here we go we're gonna start all
right uh so yeah i am going to all right guys i'm i'm a
little embarrassed of showing you my my profile right now so
I'm gonna change my icon as well
I just need you guys to know I had a really some really
rough games while trying to see if I could speedrun the
masters and like I had some I had but you can this is the
main account these are all the icons I have so so
I'm just saying I got like a little embarrassed.
Okay, look.
I'm also like, look, see, it changes every time.
Guys, it changes every time in the name.
So like, I got, okay, so the reason why I'm a little
embarrassed is that, um, I thank God I'm private profile.
But like, anyway, uh, thank God is, thank God.
This is when I used to be good.
so you get these are all the top 500 icons so like this is
when i was i used to be decent at the game and and this is
what i was complaining about like you see the icon that used
to be really pretty and they started being just guns and i
was like this is so ugly and then it was like so tiny too
This used to be like the top 500 icon in season 24 and I was
like so ugly compared to like This this was like actually so
pretty to have and then and then later on they're like oh We
should add the top 500 icon logo so people will know it's
top 500 so like at first there was no top 500 icon logo but
it's just a golden gun and it was so fucking ugly and then
yeah I miss when
And now it's just like the tag the gamer tag Which was only
available for like one season or something Yeah, so like
they had to make a lot of them that they ran out of maps
Which is understandable, you know They actually ran out of
maps for the top 500 icon
And back then top 500 was actually hard to get guys okay
back then top 500 was hard to get because there was an
actual player based chat so he can't say that it wasn't
actually pretty difficult because it wasn't masters it
wasn't masters anyway so like the reason Another reason why
I am, uh, uh, the reason why that, like, uh, I am a little
embarrassed of showing my profile at the moment is because
the most played hours on it is Kiriko, but I have a solid
30% win rate on Kiriko at the moment because every time
we're losing, I just swap to Kiriko.
Kiriko for like you know okay because like they're okay
because but because it's like well I we're losing I might as
well practice Kiriko you know that's like that's like my
mindset going in I'm like well we're losing anyway so I
think it's like a good time to practice so that's all right
like it's a it's a good time to practice her since like she
is meta so i might as well but i do play kiriko sometimes
when i don't when i'm not losing so like the moments when i
win on kiriko is when i like is when like i automatically i
pick her out of like first hand not because like you know i
was why is there a what the how many fucking okay this is
why i need to warm up oh my god i missed like 20 shots it's
because they're not training bots so like it was It's...
Oh, the falloff damage, too.
That's insane.
Where are they?
I hear them.
I hear you!
Oh, okay.
So what do you usually play?
I like Anna.
Anna's like the most fun, but then Anna also requires aim,
which like, I don't know if I have right now, because I'm
still...
I'm still waking up, guys.
Like, please, Vera, let me have this one!
Oh!
This is bullshit.
I don't know if I have the aim at the moment for Anna
because I'm still warming up.
This is different.
They're not training dummies.
They actually move.
They actually...
These people move.
Nice, I'll take that.
Jesus Christ, a fallout.
There you go.
They're not like training dummies where I know the pattern
of their movements.
These people actually have strafe patterns.
Hello?
The people are.
Oh, please.
Please be nice.
Okay, thank you.
Killing the AFK.
That's right.
I gotta take what I can get, guys.
I'm that desperate.
What the fuck is this?
Look at that Cassie falloff damage.
Holy No, bro, respect the 1v1 Okay, we're gonna bring,
alright, we're AFK now too We gotta bring down the game
volume a little bit Alright, I brought it down Let me know
what's better, sound guy Alright Yeah, exactly Oh my god,
please You guys didn't see anything No No!
No, bitch, I get away!
Oh my god, please!
I'm so angry!
Oh my god, I swear, guys, if it was not 1230, I...
I swear, if it was not 1252, I hit those.
Guys, guys, I'm just saying, you should see me in night
queues, okay?
In night queues is where I shy.
I swear In night queues is where I shine
I hit so many shots in night queues I swear to God I'm not
fucking with you guys I'm not coping You should see me in
deathmasturing night queues
I swear
it's just look things are rough right now so i brought down
the sound volume by the way sound guy it's just rough i'm
just it's just rough at the moment
i i swear when we the moment we hit the night cue time hours
i'll be like pop pop headshot headshot it's just we're we're
we're at a rough place I hear if it weren't for your
parents, you'd be as much an outlaw as me.
I know I say that, and I should definitely not play Anna
right now.
I should not.
Have mercy.
I just woke up.
Breezy, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Please.
It's just a little rough.
Look, see, it changes.
The name changes and everything.
So I'm like, I'm okay with...
Copium in this natural habitat.
So he's thinking of this to be just not copium.
It's a scientific fact.
Look, see, I hit those.
Okay, we don't hit those, but it's because he was strafing.
So like, I got confused, you know?
You know, and like...
Oh my gosh.
Ah!
Shit!
Oh, I fucking might die, though!
I told you I!
I hit those!
Bitch!
Oh, you see I hit both tracer shots too!
You guys didn't believe me.
I'm slowly waking up.
This is me and my natural habitat.
I have you.
Keep fighting.
There.
Nobody believes.
leave me until I did a fucking sick-ass shot on the tracer.
There we go.
Oh, that's not my fault.
If you die, we have a Kiriko.
We also have a Kiriko.
That is not my fault.
Please get rid of this fucking tracer.
Polish, am I the only one that hits the tracer?
It's okay.
We get like, we get like three free games.
And then if we derank, we'll call in the reinforcements.
Oh, God.
I think I might go Zen, actually.
You know what?
Alright, it's fine.
It's fine.
I'm believing you!
And he's at time!
Okay, okay.
Bro, okay, come on.
Alright, we're gonna help save our fucking junker real fast.
Whoa!
Okay, never save your junker.
Junker.
Never say Junker.
Okay.
I'm gonna go Sinjar everyone.
Okay, here we go.
Here we go.
This will work.
I swear.
Never.
I have the most healing.
You guys cannot be like, Junkie, heal your teammates.
I literally have the most healing out of both teams.
Like, look at that.
He's so scared of me now.
Look at him.
He's so fucking scared.
Okay, there you go.
Alright, we don't have cleanse.
We're so fucked.
You're so fucked.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
There you go.
Fuck you.
Never say...
Never say I'm washed.
I'm running away.
This junker has all...
This junker 100% has all...
Never say I'm washed again!
Bam!
That's when you know.
just chase your things okay here we go okay our soldier
fucking sucks bro if i'm not afraid of getting banned i
would i would say something because they're like apparently
really harsh on bans now for toxicity so i gotta i gotta
make sure I don't say anything else chat.
Apparently they're actually like banning people for shit
when it comes to toxicity
Like even you say something like bro fucking do be better at
DPS like what the fuck you can actually get banned for it
You get chat banned I've been seeing like like the it's like
a lot harsher now the moderate of the I heard like the the
Overwatch mod 2-4- oh yeah you are Kiri and he over-extend
oh my god the shit talking are Kiri because they don't heal
okay I'm gonna go more your place is where I can't heal you
I told you it's not me all right but like um but like yeah
what was it saying yeah the they like ban chat ban you or
like actually straight up ban you like a lot easily like uh
so like you say something that is any remotely toxic at all
you can actually get banned and i'm like i don't no okay
okay i griefed it okay Guys, I will admit, I actually agree.
I actually agree.
I was not paying attention.
I was looking at my chat.
Oops.
It's okay.
We can get this back.
I can have one.
I can have one game where I don't play perfectly.
Like, come on.
This is, like, the first fight where I don't play perfectly.
It's literally the first fight.
Alright.
let's see all right i'm healing you i'm doing my job i'm
doing my job okay poor soldier that poor guy
all right here we go there look at that look at what's go
look this was obviously not winnable not gonna lie it would
not matter my like the best game of my life.
They're like, yeah, this team is not salvageable.
It's not salvageable at all.
All right, where is...
She recalls here.
She blinks here.
Hello.
Thank you.
Soldier, are you?
Okay, I was gonna say, Soldier, please.
So are you serious?
And then you flip it?
okay all right this is a little this is a little tilting he
actually let it flip holy shit all right look at him run all
right there we flipped it back we didn't even oh my god we
literally got the point for eight percent come on bro you're
full healed look i played a almost perfect game chat like
whoops okay it was almost perfect guys but i know damn well
these guys are not playing any perfect these guys are
definitely a far from perfect oh my oh my god thank fucking
god look this is top 500 reaction time right there holy shit
oh my god
Alright, top 500 reaction time.
How did I live?
I shifted.
You can shift an alt form now, which is great.
That's...
That makes me very happy.
But yeah, you can shift an alt form.
Yeah, that's right.
Look at that fucking reflexes.
They definitely have junker alt, so I'm both going to save
my shift.
See, I need to charge up my fucking huge.
too And where will you be okay?
She's not gonna be okay.
I told you it's not my fun I swear wait does she not have
cleanse?
Okay, I was gonna say oh Fucking dead no matter what It
doesn't matter It doesn't fucking matter a team will be dead
no matter what I'm not playing on up because like this team
does not deserve my on up like especially this fucking
venture like nothing will save this venture no matter what
hero i play go life weaver no life weaver i i i still don't
know how to play because life weaver was locked for the
longest time until they were like we're gonna make every
hero free but like But like, I actually do not know how to
play the line.
What do you mean?
Please!
Holy shit!
We don't deserve to win this.
Oh my god.
Please!
How do you have nine deaths?
Oh my god.
5,000 and two more heals than said oh my god bro all right
oh yeah the i'm the one that's not getting flamed is
definitely throwing they were flaming the fucking you cannot
blame me for the loss because i i have the most healing out
of two I have the most healing.
Okay, we have like one more game to like protect our...
I protect our healer.
And then I'll call in reinforcements.
I'm gonna call it...
If the games get more rough, I'll call it in reinforcements.
You're the support.
They always bring...
Yes, but like I wasn't the problem, guys.
You can't blame me when I'm not the problem.
Oh my god, I almost fucking...
What the fuck?
What?
He fucking flicked me!
Holy shit, the fucking turret bait!
That's actually crazy.
The turret bait.
There we go.
Watch that.
Look at that flick.
Guys.
Look at that fucking flick.
Oh.
Guys, his straight pattern.
His straight pattern.
I couldn't download it in time.
I couldn't.
Oh, I'm scared.
Oh, I hear him.
There you go.
Look at that.
I should have done the cool guys.
Don't look at.
Oh, you see that headshot?
You see that?
That's fucking right.
That's right.
My first headshot of the day.
Oh, God.
Oh, never mind.
That's her 20th headshot of the day.
Guys, this helps me warm up.
Okay, I need this.
Okay, guys.
Thank you for the shot.
Ooh, a Reaper.
You know what?
Maybe that will hit somebody.
Come on, Junker.
Oh, God.
Oh, no!
Guys, never go inside a tight corridor with a Junker at.
oh we did it see i'm waking up guys i'm waking up look i'm
gonna grief somebody's top 500 game i told you guys no
matter what i will eventually grief someone's top 500 game
right here
all right all right does this team deserve does this team
deserve my my honor we'll see All right, let me grab and
reinforcements just in case.
All right.
Uh, uh, uh, uh, um.
Leave a broken world behind.
Maybe one day we'll go on missions in Hawaii.
Okay, there we go.
Guys, I got the, I have the, I have the, uh, reinforcements
on, on backup.
Just in case.
Just in case this match goes terribly wrong.
kizato thank you for the super chat thank you believe in
grumpy pants all right we'll see i like realize like what is
a streamer mode name too like like what names are streamer
modes so many people um so many people are using streamer
mode these days i mean it would make sense because like you
know you could flame somebody and then like they won't know
it's you
insurance oh my god it's from matra it's from matra oh my
shit's fucking bugging holy i love hearing that don't you
love it when your tank is like oh my shit is bugging like
it's just freaking out i'm like please you're literally a
tank please don't do this to me just leave leave the game
okay i'm good okay i'm good ash one Oh my god.
You know, you love hearing your fucking tank being like, oh
man, my shit's bugging bro.
He's good.
Guys, he's good now guys.
He's good now.
Everything's okay.
Look at that.
I can hit a tracer.
Well, psych.
Just gave you guys a little of a heart attack, but it's
okay.
Everything's fine now.
teammates on your toes exactly all right you're fine yeah
yeah see i might have missed like two more shots but you see
no it's a sigma wait they were sigma this entire time i hate
playing on against shields it's like not fun like i i like i
guess like riding shields is okay but like
Okay, I don't have to...
Oh!
Please!
Please, I...
I've done everything I could...
No, no.
Where's... Where's the...
Doom!
Please!
Peak me!
I've been trying to kill you this entire time!
I've been trying to...
I've been trying to fucking queue our doom!
Are you fucking kidding?
Oh my god, Piconto!
Go!
Beconto!
Beconto, please!
Holy shit!
Who is he?
It's fine.
He didn't need my ult.
I saved my ult for next fight, guys.
That was intentional.
Because I knew he would clutch this.
This was the same guy where his shit was bugging.
It was the same guy.
Don't butterfly him.
Oh my god.
Please.
This is how much I believe in him.
I believe in you.
I believe in you, Picanto!
Picanto, you got this!
Picanto!
Where is he?
Wait, where is Picanto?
There he is.
Look at that.
See?
This man.
This man deserves it.
Cool guys, don't look at it.
Don't look at maids.
But then I missed.
Maybe I should start looking.
Okay, we're fine.
See?
We are so fine.
We're so healthy.
Look at that.
They didn't see.
The condom did not see.
He didn't see.
Okay, that was a little embarrassing.
Big antsy.
Always believe in Picanto.
Guys, look.
I've warmed up in everything, but like...
I've warmed up in everything.
What the fuck is he doing here?
Oh my god, what are they all doing here?
Oh god.
He has all...
He actually has...
Oh There I hit it there.
I hit it guys I I redeemed myself Everything there is paying
94.
Thank you for the super chat.
There see I hit those I hit the aunties I Told you I told
you It was a it was a bait chat.
It was just a bait Damn, if you miswrite, look, I get one
mistake.
Oh, oh, yeah.
So, like, look, every game, I get one mistake.
This is my one.
That's how I realized.
I realized I was like, my mic was too low a bit when that
was a little too low.
Every game, I just, I get one mistake.
This is my one.
behind this is my one guys um all right here let's go only
one freebie look we're still gonna win regardless unless we
don't fucking get past the first uh the first what is it
called oh my gosh overwatch terms i already forgot overwatch
terms guys where does where does checkpoints yeah the first
checkpoint it's fine the first yeah guys this is how washed
i am i actually don't remember overwatch terms at the moment
here we go it's okay we can do this i didn't get this top
500 spray to miss my aunties holy shit he's gonna straight
to point they might have seen me okay ow no i lived though
you guys ready i'm like on their hand and they're No, we are
absolutely not ready.
Guys, guys, there is actually a chance we might lose.
There's...
It's crazy for me to say, but we live in a world where we
could actually lose.
Oh, look at that!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
Okay, we're fine.
We're okay.
I'm gonna swap off, because, like, I am not playing.
into this.
I'm not playing Anna into this.
No, fuck that shit.
This is too much.
I refuse to heal through a Sigma shield.
Alright, Kirko.
Guys, it's not because we're losing them swapping to Kirko.
It just makes sense.
I hate playing Anna against Sigma.
Okay, guys.
It's not because I'm giving up.
Guys, it actually makes sense to play Kiriko in this
scenario.
Wait, we should fucking push up because...
Yeah.
Oh.
There we go.
See?
Look at that.
We're slowly but surely raising our Kiriko win rate.
I told you, it makes sense to play Kiriko.
This was my first death, by the way.
way i only have one death guys one death that's how you
fucking play support
all right i'll just be like invite me whenever invite me at
whenever
there you go all right even though we won that game even
though we won that game like i wait oops sorry let's just
get some overwatch to insurance in here we're still uh we're
not gonna be in like a voice chat with them though we're
just gonna be like chilling but condo was good he actually
hard carried us he hard carried oh my god let's go picanto
oh wait all right never mind we get we have to we play
another one because our insurance isn't even ready Rank
insurance time.
Our insurance was not ready.
So we play another.
Alright, we need to slowly warm back up or aim anyway.
That's fine.
Alright, watch this guys.
Craziest headshot you're gonna see.
Craziest headshot.
Right here.
What the fuck kind of fight is going on right now?
I told you.
What?
Shit!
I told you, I told you craziest headshot you're ever gonna
see.
Whoa, whoa, hey guys, hey.
Calm down!
Hey guys, calm down!
Let me regen my fucking HP.
She's popping off.
There you go, I told you.
Okay, look, I popped off.
the beginning though lucy is our heart to hit okay they're
all like look at them fucking riding around like a little
rat come on come on lucio also sound guy like adjusted my
mic a little bit sounds still okay unless sound guy like
left after it pieced out after that bro fuck off bro what
the fuck there's a hammond don't make me fucking come up
here that's fucking right i can jump that's too this please
res me you get to like see all the streamer mode names while
you're playing
and you're gonna fucking suzu but you can't suzu from these
shots look at that wait is it just me and uh oh no it's me
kiriko and sombra where the fuck's the sombra oh oh oh yeah
it's never a good idea the fucking hide in you in front of a
Kiriko.
Oh, whoa!
Whoa!
Please spare me.
Potato, thank you for the super sticker.
Thank you, thank you.
I'm going to AFK for an hour.
Can I see you later?
Jesse, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, God.
I hate soldier and strafes.
Please, fight each other and then let me take two kills.
Fight each other, please.
There we go.
Oh, no!
Who expected the fourth party?
Who expected that?
You know, I'm inspired now.
I'm not inspired.
I haven't played Tracer in so long.
Guys, it's been a while since I played Tracer.
Oh, God, not against Kierkega.
Playing against Kierkega with Tracer is like playing against
my character.
Oh god, that's scary.
Oh, it's like one headshot away.
Oh, please have mercy.
What's that?
I see here, Lucio.
Okay, full regen.
Because I don't know my map health packs.
That's the only reason to play Tracer.
You know where all the health packs are, but I don't.
That's the thing.
Oh.
No!
Here we go.
I take those.
I'm desperate.
No!
Okay.
Where is...
It's okay.
I'm rank 1 in deathmatch.
Guys, don't talk to me unless you're rank 1 in deathmatch.
Where the fuck is he?
Oh shit.
Okay, watch this.
Whoa, Sombra.
Oh, no, I don't have Blinks anymore.
No.
I got...
Bro, there was three people.
Does anyone get the license plate?
It's not fair.
There was, like, three.
I'm one tracer.
Oh, my God.
Why is it all Kirko's?
Please.
Is it just Kierko's?
Where the fuck is the widow?
Let me farm this widow.
Okay.
Oh, I hear him.
Bro, stop following me!
Bro, leave me alone!
Farm somebody else!
Where's this widow?
I'm gonna...
Oh, there he is.
Please!
Let me farm this widow!
Oh my god, it's worth it
Bro, it's not my fault I literally have like three people on
my ass Bro, bitch Bro, fuck off I fucking farmed her Leave
me alone Okay, where's the widow?
I wanna make that widow leave I hear Yeah, oh
There you go fuck oh fuck okay give me a sec give me a sec
Give me a sec All right, don't worry bro, what the fuck this
here goes just annoying us There you go.
They don't know.
Oh god.
They don't know I'm here.
I need a regen because I don't know where the health packs
are.
I don't know where the health packs are.
Bro!
Okay.
Okay, nice.
I got the Kiriko kill.
She's just watching.
It made me...
It gave me performance anxiety when he just started
watching.
Like...
I don't know what to do Oh thank god It's okay We in the
game We in the game Actually a hunting party
They were judging me They were looking at me It happens to
all of us Can I play Mercy?
Guys Do I get my one my one mercy game
yes have I proven myself enough to have one mercy game
look I get I get one mistake and one mercy game do I can I
not can I not try anymore
crack now.
You say that and then you get, like, you get, like, two guys
yelling at you because you're playing Mercy.
Playing Mercy would be the mistake.
Guys, sometimes a support player just want to play Mercy,
okay?
They just want to play Mercy and just relax, alright?
Guys, I need you to know that that sometimes people just
don't want to aim and that's why Mercy and Brigette was
born.
That widow?
That's why I don't I personally don't like this map if they
have a good widow.
Oh.
Oh, he fucking dead.
Okay, I should play Kiriko.
I'll save the Doom and then I'm going to swap the Kiriko
because we need a cleanse.
Alright.
Guys, it's not because we were losing.
It just makes sense to play Kiriko.
Okay, guys.
Sometimes I play to pick Kiriko because it's...
It makes sense.
Alright.
He was just pepper spraying me so I was just like, whatever.
Guys, there are moments when I pick her because she just was
the character to play.
Alright, we're fine.
We're fine.
Even if we lose, we have a demotion protection.
Oh my god, please.
Please.
Do one damage.
Oh, guys, it's fine.
I'm alive.
I am... I am not alive anymore.
Please tell me you're not DOOM 1 trick.
Please tell me you're not DOOM 1 trick because we really
need you to be somebody else.
They are hard counting you, my dude.
They are hard countering you.
Oh, thank God.
Okay, they missed.
Are you serious?
Okay, that was a mistake.
I swear to God, please just be alive.
This is all I want.
Be alive.
He has all.
Winston has all.
Winston...
Why are you there?
All tombs are...
Not anymore.
There's just tombs that, like...
Oh.
Okay.
All right, they wasted that.
That's good.
They wasted the all.
They wasted it all.
We're fine.
Yeah, there's structures there now.
There's new stuff.
There's so many new things.
It's okay.
Maybe our doom.
Maybe our doom will swap.
Oh, thank fucking God.
I honestly never expected him to swap, but thank God.
Also, nobody talks in Overwatch anymore.
It's actually sad.
Everyone just plays the game.
There you go.
That's how you're headshot.
Wait, I think he still has all.
I don't think he's expected to get burned that quickly.
Look at that.
Look at that headshot.
Oh, look at that.
That was not a headshot, but look at that, though.
Jesus Christ, please.
There's too many flankers.
Okay.
Alright.
kill him no one nope nope nope nope nope are you serious
sometimes there's too many things i can't fucking do
everything it's fine we're okay please please anybody please
i'm about to be at 2k damage be that the same damage as our
Sombra.
It's okay.
As long as I don't publicly say the toxic stuff to them,
we're fine.
Like how trash this Tracer is.
He should uninstall this game right now.
But it's okay.
Please, Bap!
Oh my team!
Oh my Yeah, it's okay.
We have rank insurance later This is the reason look it's
not me that I have a 30% win rate It's not my fault that I
have a 30% win rate on Kierkega It's just it's unwinnable
I'm in an unwinnable scenario like He's only 14 years old
It's look I swear to God.
It's not a me issue when it comes to Kiriko
I swear to God My team my team is just
Let's just say say they could be held back a grade let's
just say that i'm out here skipping five grades my teammates
are still fucking in kindergarten like look you can't blame
me i have the wait shit this this kid never mind i don't
have my sprays on this guy that's a nice way to say it look
guys i'm PMA positive mental attitude positive mental
attitude chat it's all about being positive yay yay okay how
much you want BEM to run up this wall and then get headshot
nope I didn't thank fucking god thank god I had somebody I
had one of my friends call me like a heal bot on Kiriko
because all I do was like heal instead of like dpsing um and
then i like 1v1ed them on kiriko and then i fucking shit on
them we did like we had like a 1v1 session on kiriko and i
had like i think it was like 20 to 10.
i was like say that shit again
i was like well fuck you who said i'm a heal bot on kiriko
It's not my fault that my team keeps fucking dying so I
can't DPS like it's not my fault
Okay, look that okay, I might have missed shots there But
like guys, okay This is different this is different the
strength was insane the strength pattern was insane
It's different.
I'm not a heal bot on Kiriko.
Alright, I can also DPS too.
But like I need to win the game so I can't fucking try to
prove a point at the moment.
Because I need to make sure my team's alive.
Like I said, it's not my fault that I'm healing so much on
Kiriko.
Like I have to keep them alive.
Look, I have to keep him alive!
Oh my god, I swear, please poke please.
I need heals.
I please don't let this monkey kill me I don't let this
monkey kill me All right, there you go.
All right, anyway, Panzer thank you for the finishing gift
this ship.
Thank you.
Thank you
Okay, that's fine All right making sure you're alive making
sure you're alive too.
Alright.
There you go.
You forgot it.
Alright, we're fine.
We're fine.
See?
Headshot.
Boom.
Climb the wall.
Headshot.
Boom!
There you go.
Easy.
Oh god.
Oh.
Oh god, alright, we're fine.
Everything is okay.
Everything, the most, we're totally gonna lose this.
Wait, wait, wait.
I actually have...
Wait!
No, we're totally gonna lose this.
I'm going in with zero confidence here.
I honestly do not...
not think that this is winnable.
Unless I do have my rush.
Yeah, Masters is top 500 now.
If you're in Diamond, I think Masters is Diamond 5.
Or Diamond, not Diamond 5, Diamond 1?
Maybe?
Maybe Diamond 1?
It's okay!
I'm protecting you!
Everything will be fine!
Are you fucking... I... I can't I can't believe it.
My rush got fucking eliminated.
My rush actually got eliminated by a hack.
Oh god, this might be where I die.
This might be where I die.
Oh god.
Oh.
I'm that good.
I didn't need rush.
I'm so good that I don't even need rush.
You got this.
Who the fuck needs rush?
I'm that good.
Never judge me.
I have to...
Okay, don't look at this, though.
Don't look at this.
Look at the heals.
I am not a heal bot.
But I kept my team alive.
I'm the same.
I'm not a heal bot on Kiriko.
Guys, I'm not a heal bot on Kiriko.
I had more damage than our BAP on Kiriko.
That's so different.
It's okay.
We have rank insurance now.
We have rank insurance.
We don't.
We don't talk about our fucking accuracy.
Not a heal bot.
Look at the...
That's different.
I had to heal that much because my team was dying.
Look, we're slowly but surely raising our...
Kiriko win rate, guys.
One, thank, welcome to, welcome back to Tamayo Fire, welcome
back.
Um, straight, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank
you, guys.
Guys, okay, look, in Overwatch is actually not a compliment
what I found out.
how do I know?
I've surprisingly been called a heal bot on Kiriko.
Not, not just once.
Like, it was like heal bot quote unquote derogatory
so i so unfortunately that's how i know the heal bot is not
the way to go why is it that bad because when you're playing
kierko the issue you're supposed to put in the dps as well
when you're playing kierko too but like i apparently i i I
do not put in enough TPS for them to be happy about it.
Yo, yo, how you guys doing?
Holy shit, he's loud.
Give me a sec.
We're gonna, I'm gonna have to adjust the fucking thing.
All right, give me a sec.
We gotta adjust, how do you adjust the fucking volume?
Is there like individual volume sliders?
Oh my god, that's so loud.
Oh my god.
Okay, wait.
voice chat oh is it because like voice chat volume is like
i'm putting at 75 there we go guys i'm not throwing i'm not
throwing it's my time wait i'm a sombra oh my god okay
there's no reason to play mercy with sombra tracer with two
flankers there's no reason guys i'm not picking kyrko i'm
not picking Kiriko because I'm throwing.
It's because cop-wise, I have to.
Sometimes you just have to play these characters.
But it doesn't mean you're throwing.
Thank you.
It's just not...
Oh, please, Ruben, you are my rank insurance.
If I start losing without rank insurance, what does that say
about my insurance?
Okay.
All right.
Okay, we have Anna.
Okay, we have two flankers.
You can't blame my team.
Everybody's playing, everybody playing the required
character, except for our DPS, which is unfortunately like,
you know, what we need good DPS.
I should have avoided this, Sombra.
There's rank insurance now.
Yes, my rank insurance is called having a duo.
That's my rank insurance.
Look, I did have a pause.
Is he still holding it?
He's still holding it.
Is my head peeking?
We're fine.
See?
We're okay.
All right, we're all here.
Look.
Oh my god, thank god.
He's playing soldier now.
Oh, thank god.
Okay.
All right, and then he died.
But that's okay.
It's okay.
He's dead.
Okay.
All right.
This is fine.
They used coffee and they used rush.
I think I won more being solo.
I'm just all I'm saying is that I won more games playing
solo.
We'll be able to walk out of spawn.
It'll be beautiful.
All right.
Wait, I think I can like chill now.
We have Ana, we have Soldier and we have Ash.
Nice.
Alright.
This is it.
Here's my rush so I can swap later.
It's okay.
It's just on Reuben.
It's fine.
He's fine.
Look, he's so healthy.
Look at that.
He took two.
Oh, and then our soldier died.
Oh, and then our other DPS died.
Okay.
This just wasn't the game.
This is just not the game.
This is just...
It's her news.
It's alright.
We're just...
We were not meant to win this.
It was canon.
It was fucking...
Yo, I can...
I can recontest with flex.
It was just canon.
It was just...
No, he's not!
Where is our he is?
What do you mean are his what do you mean okay all I'm
saying is that the rank insurance kicks in now it kicks in
the rank insurance it's gonna kick in now that was bad
I would type where the DPS at look I would too but I'm also
afraid of getting I'm getting banned because because they're
very strict now about banning people they're very strict now
and I don't want to get chat banned guys I really do not
want to get chat banned like Even for like stuff like guys,
I get one guys.
I get one game My one game of mercy like how every game I
get one like how every game I get like one mistake Every
every three games I get one chance to play mercy
Dude, I'm so ready to win first game of the day day feeling
fresh and ready
you clearly missed the payment on your rank insurance don't
worry i got you don't keep bacon thank you for the akasupa
thank you thank you you're right you're right bacon my rank
insurance starts now it starts now this is where it starts
one game on mercy it'll be fine where am I oh there it is oh
run oh it is so easy this is so easy they're on run that's
like automatically easy game this guy is fucking surfing on
the railing okay okay I sort of threw there okay wait wait
wait wait winnable winnable no you're dead but it's Okay.
Okay.
I threw a little bit, but like, it was a joke.
It was like, it was just a joke, guys.
There's soldiers won!
There's a Zen wanting it back.
All right, focus now.
I'm focused now.
Guys.
I'm not pistoling because I'm throwing.
I'm pistoling because I want to get the Zenyata out of the
way.
Oh God, please live, Ana.
Please fucking live.
Okay, here you go.
There you go.
See?
Fine.
We're fine.
look look at look at all the look at all the sounds that
means my dps is doing great the most engaging gameplay ever
here we go come on get a kill you got this you're oh Okay.
He's 1 HP.
Okay.
I'm not mad.
It's okay.
That's fine.
Now you get your kill.
Now you get your one.
You get your one right here.
Right here.
That's right!
That's right, small pup!
You get your one kill right here!
Right here is where you get your one kill!
This is it!
Small pup!
I won't stop healing you until...
Small pup, please!
Oh, he did it.
She did it.
She fucking did it.
I believed.
Oh my god.
There we go.
It's fine.
The hero we all deserved.
She got her one kill.
We did it.
Now I don't have the damage booster anymore.
Oh my god.
Is Ruben okay?
I'm not okay.
I am not okay.
Oh my god.
Two kills!
I'm never done.
doubted you.
Never doubted you for a second.
What the fuck was that Rhine Shatter?
It was called Optimism.
Oh, she is so fucking dead.
She's so fucking dead.
She's so... Oh, please.
No!
I just needed one poke!
Just one fucking poke, man!
Oh my god, that tracking's beautiful, though.
Please.
Just one poke.
Oh my god, I'm taking a nap.
all right it's fine i will res her and then nothing bad
happened all right here we can kill bastion all right we can
also see it'll be fine i'll meet you you won't die on my
watch i can kill this guy he's getting healed what is going
on over there how is he getting healed passively why is
there a road i shot him how did the regen Okay, we're fine.
Okay, that's fine.
Later.
See?
We're in there.
We're in a stage of it's fine and it's not fine.
But it'll be fine.
Oh, no.
It's not fine anymore.
I'm swapping.
There's no reason to play.
I win these.
That's a crazy thing.
All right, let's see.
I'm going to play.
I'm going to play Kiriko.
On land, I would have won that.
guys it's always about the cleanse it's so over him we're so
back we need to get rid of aunties we're gonna up our win
percentage on this character guys it's gonna work we're
gonna up our win percentage what the fuck he's like one holy
shit i am just gonna walk i'm just gonna wait here.
This is how.
Is he fine?
I don't think he's fine.
I don't think he was fine.
That means because I refunded my mercy, because I refunded
my mercy, that means I get to play mercy next game because I
did a refund and got my money back.
So I have one refund.
that's how it works i got my money back and i got a refund
refunds guarantee we're gonna kill the soge i'm gonna ship
my pants is he okay dude i know uh oh poor guy
all right i did not wake him up everybody else woke him up
we went we went we went guys it wasn't me oh wait oh my god
oh my god they're getting kids go go go now we're not gonna
let the rodents stay on the point for five hours wait where
where is the hammond i can't see the hammond nice they don't
have an honor and they don't have sleep please just shoot
him shoot him he's so low oh my god thank god at least shoot
him
Can you shoot him, too?
No, okay, we're good.
We're good.
This is happening.
There's an armor running away.
We're going to exit.
I told you.
I told...
Look, maybe Mercy was just not the pick.
Guys, maybe Mercy was like 100% not the pick.
He's slamming me.
We're going to kill him a little bit.
Just make...
I'm not sure yet.
I need more data.
And I need...
He's one!
Just a maybe.
all right we're fine i have rush
there you're welcome tracer now i never have to heal her
again she can't complain because i saved her life one time
that's how it works being a support player wait what the
fuck okay we got our one what the fuck got my one too where
why is there a fucking oh Oh, shit.
I'm not going to look.
Can we kill this rodent?
Look at this guy.
Okay, there we go.
What the fuck was this Ana doing there?
Not a heal bot.
I have less damage than our Ana.
But I was also playing...
Wait, no!
Of course I have less damage.
I was playing fucking...
I was playing fucking mercy.
I'm about to lap the Ana.
Ana and damage.
That's embarrassing.
Kill him now.
No, he died!
Oh, wait.
I'm almost there.
Oh, okay.
There you go.
Headshot.
Oh, God!
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Oh, it's not fine.
I ran away.
Oh, no.
It's okay.
There you go.
it's fine I need my damage oh there's a reaper it's fine
we're okay Jesus Christ you're doing great we capped it's
okay that's what matters just like Tanimura all over again
all I'm saying chat all I'm saying is that I was mercy for
like 60% of that game and I'm already almost the same damage
as our Anna.
That's all I'm saying.
I'm not saying that our Anna was bad.
I'm saying that I'm really good.
I'm just saying I was pretty good with that fucking damage
there.
Like...
look all right i think i want to play zen yada actually
should i play zen is it worth it i'm gonna do it i'm gonna
do it i'll play kyrko if we die maybe 30.
maybe 30 of us is strong maybe 30 percent i literally
swapped when we were here that's like literally 60 percent
you see the trailer for the new hero shooter marvel yeah i
did and then i accidentally called called the the water guy
uh aquaman because i literally forgot the marble water guy
rolling around you know super chat envy i'm really excited
though i'm really really excited
i really i'm really looking forward to it we need like i
just want a good fps game i'm tired of all like the the
realism ones what the is he what He's like...
Okay.
Alright.
Wait, what?
Um, yeah, our hogs did.
Our fucking tracer was AFK.
I'm tired of all the realism shooters, like the...
What was it?
Like, the PUBGs and the Tarkovs.
I just want, like, more of, like, non-realism shooters.
Realism shooters just die so fast.
It's just not fun for me.
Why is there a floating orb?
No!
What?
The ride is a floating orb!
I don't check that!
I literally can't see the ride!
I'm like, no!
It's back!
It's fine.
The ride is a floating orb!
the ride.
I actually can't see the ride.
What is this bug?
That bug only existed when my drives were crashing.
Oh no.
I actually can't see where the ride is.
That's so bad.
I'm sorry I can't see the ride.
Holy shit.
I don't see this.
What is this bug?
I haven't had that bug.
It's so large.
It's just orbs.
Okay.
We can also kill Ryan.
Oh, if I don't know where that ride is, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
I can't see him.
I... That's a dead body.
Okay, we know that.
I can't actually...
don't know what this is so bad this is actually so bad oh my
god okay oh no i i'm gonna assume the ride heart is with the
team right he has he has to be with the team that's the ride
the tiny orb right here that's him Are you serious?
Oh.
He has played.
He has played now.
I got sled by our fuckiana.
What the fuck is this bug?
It's alright.
This is...
This is a little awkward.
Wait!
I'm an orange too!
Guys!
At least I can see the Rhine now.
I can see the Rhine.
It's fine.
I can't see anything else.
But I can see the Rhine though.
It's just Genji, Manoblady.
You can't die fast.
You're kidding.
It's okay.
I can see the ride now.
Guys, I can see.
It's actually a really big one.
Yes.
And they all just...
Oh my god, I was going to say.
Guys, I don't think my rank insurance is working, guys.
I have realized my rank insurance is absolutely not working.
I'm an or.
I don't know what's going on There's two orns Oh We're all
orns
Guys I'm losing with the rank insurance I think I might need
a refund It might need a refund My insurance has like I was
winning more As soon as I got rank insurance, I think I got
sold a scam.
Guys, as soon as I got rank insurance, I've been losing
games.
People are turning into orbs.
Things was not going so well for me.
Oh my god, I see my hands.
Holy shit.
I can see my arms now!
This is it!
Alright.
I'm not saying Ruben's scammed me.
We've got a rock win and we win.
That's it.
Not saying.
I hope I can see you right.
Tank who's 14 and 10.
Alright, here you go.
I refuse.
I refuse to lose to that guy.
To be fair, one of our DPS has like 11 deaths.
All right, there you go.
We're not orbs anymore.
This is it.
Guys, they're on Rhine and Zen again.
We're not orbs.
But somebody's an orb.
All right, this is a little awkward.
Oh, this is so awkward.
Where is the Rhine?
What?
Where's the big, fucking fat ride?
I'm the most worried.
I think the most worried part is...
Is I'm scared.
I'm fucking...
I won't be able to see the pin.
I will not be...
I 100% will not be...
I definitely will not be able to see my fucking ride.
Wait, big, big, big, big, big.
Someone else to step on the point.
There you go.
Oh, that's so easy.
I'm gonna go for the Ana.
Where are you, Ruben?
Where are they?
Oh, what is this fucking bug?
What?
Oh, no, what is he?
What is he?
What hero is he?
Okay, do him.
Okay, all right, Doom.
Okay.
What is that, Firewall?
Thank you.
Okay.
We don't...
It's that ride.
That's ride.
That's...
Okay.
I'm gonna hope everybody will be fine.
Wait, what is that?
What is that?
Is that a Doom?
I'm still here.
Just give me a sec to...
I might need to restart my game.
I might need it.
Oh my god.
I couldn't even see the orb.
I'm restarting game.
Oh my god.
I'm one game away from the right game.
okay all right we're gonna restart we're gonna i don't know
what happened i honestly i never the last time this happened
was like years ago so battle of the goddamn orbs orbs join
now bro i was just having too good of a good thing and then
their game was like you're having fun and overwatch i well
then doki we're not gonna let you have that there's an orb
among us you're just like you're having good you have a good
time how dare you now here you can't see half of the players
on this lobby too and and fun can't be in the same set how
dare you start having fun on overwatch
that was actually crazy that actually like when the when
when it was like a doom echo when it was a doom echo i
literally could not see the doom like that was so big brain
that was actually so fucking big brain like like i can't
believe it i can't believe that happened that's actually
crazy all right here we go we'll be fine this time this time
guys this is it oh watch too okay let me because like my
drives aren't my drives are not crashing i know that for
sure because like last time Last time when we had Orbs in
Overwatch, it was because, like, my PC was fucking dying.
This is still not the...
I'm not using my new PC yet, because I haven't had time to
set up my new PC.
But, like, okay.
Your storage space, this is probably being used by something
else.
Check Task Manager.
Oh, no.
How bad is my storage space right now?
Can't be that bad.
Yeah, it's not even that bad.
It's not, like, my storage space is at 41%.
What the fuck?
I just hope my PC isn't great.
Same thing happens.
The mod up.
Very common on my...
Oh no.
Is it...
Is it my game?
Is it my PC?
Well no.
It's my PC.
If everybody's orbs again here.
But thing is.
I play so much.
I think it's because I'm streaming.
Maybe it's because I'm streaming that the games are getting
rough.
Like...
Is it me?
Am I the problem?
Am I the issue here?
All right, no worry.
Well, no.
I got my refund so I can play Mercy again.
I got my refund, guys.
Is everybody loaded in?
Everybody's loaded in.
It was not me.
It was a game.
Look, see?
Dude, okay, this is my off-wall, Mandy.
Okay, it's...
Look, look, see?
It's not...
See?
You used to be a tanker.
There's a...
There's no orange.
wasn't me.
It was not me.
I fucking knew it wasn't me.
It's never me.
About checking the archives.
It was not me.
Good luck with that.
Alright.
It's okay.
I can play...
I can play murky.
Murky time.
Yay!
Murky time!
All right, it's time for relaxation after or watch it's or
watch time All right, here you go look see so relaxing Don't
have to try just crouch So everything's fine.
It was just a little scare Just a little bit of a scare
right here see everything's okay all right ash go and do
your thing let me hear the fucking let me hear the ding ding
sounds at least let me hear some headshots oh wait we we can
push this freely you know what i'll take a free push
okay it wasn't as free as i thought it was Apparently it was
not free of course there's no you don't get things in life
for free I forgot about that Kill their mercy if they can
kill me you can kill their mercy It's a rule of law where's
the door There you are yes blade he's gaming all right I
believe in him They remember the payload existed why why do
they always remember it at the worst possible for me I think
they just hate youtubers they knew they knew look I'm
getting targeted all I'm saying is that I'm getting targeted
right now on land I win those all right this time okay I'm
gonna focus yeah I'm gonna focus Guys Guys Look, all I'm
saying is not me I'm just getting targeted I can't fucking
avoid forever Stream sniping How could they stream sniping?
I can't believe they would do this To banish Banshee?
I can't believe it They do this for the up and coming
streamer Banshee It's so fucked up Oh no Oh no, it's okay, I
can fly up in the air.
Where?
Where was my echo?
Okay, my echo fucking flew away from me and I couldn't fly
up in the air.
Oh my god Oh my god
All I'm saying is that I couldn't fly in the air Okay, I
couldn't fly
Guys, this is the Overwatch experience guys Guys, I'm going
to report this guy, and I hope he gets spanked.
Okay, no grass.
Okay, okay.
No grass.
I'm playing.
I fucking healed as best I could in this scenario.
I'm so good at plans, dude.
I might be a genius.
Guys, it's not me.
I swear to God.
I swear to God, it's not me.
Oh my god.
Guys, this is why you don't play.
This is why...
Mercy...
I say whatever you want about Curie.
All I'm saying...
All I'm saying is that...
Playing Mercy is pretty rough.
Look, it's my team.
Mercy is only as good as the team.
Alright.
I hope the Echo dies.
That's all I'm saying.
Holy shit.
I'm just getting targeted.
I'm 100% getting targeted.
There's no way.
There's no way I die every time.
They have nothing because they also just use high noon.
Oh, wait.
Did I, like, res that?
Maybe I should res that.
Should I wait?
No.
Oh, they probably have high noon.
I'll just wait.
All right, I'm going to go maybe.
I'm just going to walk on this sick.
I'll go do the echo.
Something a horrible person would do.
But it would be a shame if the echo dies.
Oh.
It'll be a shame
I didn't say it was a shame look he get pot.
I told you you can't help him You can't fucking help him.
He dies with a pocket He fucking dies with a pocket.
You can't save him.
Oh my god.
Holy shit You can't heal stupid If he dies with a pocket,
you can't fucking save him!
I knew it wasn't me.
I fucking knew it wasn't me!
I knew I was getting targeted!
I fucking knew it!
I'm swapping.
Fuck this bitch.
Fuck this horror.
I was justified!
I will never save him.
I hope you guys in the game.
They are not in voice.
All right, bye.
Sorry, Overwatch puts me through a really rough place.
Welcome to the Overwatch experience.
God, it will be a shame if you die.
Yo, this guy put his window down and I This guy put his
fucking ammo down My host of window I'm so mad He's so dead
Bro, back up, bro Bro, why are you still Why are you
healing?
What?
Oh my god, why?
Why?
Reset!
Okay.
I thought more of you were alive.
Oh well.
We need more of us were alive.
It was two supports and I'm Hey, what the fuck am I supposed
to do?
On top of your head.
All right, I have us soon.
Duplicating Sigma.
Oh, you did get the Sigma.
Good for him.
Doing the bare fucking minimum.
Oh, this is where I die.
Big fucks, big fucks.
shit what a fucking okay not gonna lie that was i that was
an insane combo bro this kid's fucking five
what what i i literally swapped some anna i don't think that
was on her honor and that was definitely not on me i that
what i literally swapped the ada on the last thing this kid
is like 12.
this kid is 12.
there's no way i'm gonna this never peaked masters on an on
your level 321 account except for support except
Shit, you're fucking trash kid.
You're actually trash Fuck you You're the only one on this
team without any healing What are you doing inappropriate
text chat voice chat?
Okay, I should say underage Blaming everyone but yours but
yourself I did not I did not say all that Thank you.
Toxic as hell.
Bro, go back to school.
Just kidding.
At his age, I was fucking top 500.
What the fuck is this kid doing?
He is like high school and still diamond.
Fucking learn the game.
This game's been out for like seven plus years and you're
still diamond.
Don't be a diamond shitter.
Oh my god Imagine fucking still being a diamond shitter
After like And not peeking more than that Oh it'll be a
shame if he dies Yeah oh man why is there a cast there I
will not let them rise I'm gonna stand here menacingly
Alright Oh man sucks that fucking he's dead so sad oh my god
sucks that he's dead kill this guy right now i'm heading
over everybody gets heals except for except for the except
for that guy oh my god yo thank you thank you you're fine
you're fine
honestly you're just mad she's go busting
look if you're you guys are still diamond after seven years
on the game it's not you guys it's your team but this guy
this guy 100% 100% he's gonna be stuck in diamond forever
and it's because of him himself it's because it's it's
because of him individually as a player not because not
because of you guys yeah it's fine he's jumping off the map
it's fine thank you for this he's hard stuck he's fucking
hard stuck he's never gonna get past master five in his
fucking life this is after squad this is his whole thing
that he gets he gets like a shitty time at squad that he
goes and be toxic in overwatch because it's the only time he
feels powerful but thing is it will never fix how shitty of
a person he really is He'll be like, oh.
Oh, the reason why, like, people are, like, shitty towards
me is because other people are shitty.
But no, he's just an asshole.
Yo, kill this guy.
Oh, I...
Damn, dude.
Oh, my God, that's sleeping?
I did.
I must have sleeping.
I was gonna say.
He might res this, though.
Oh It's fine.
They didn't get the res off that's fine.
Oh We don't have a cure go Okay, I'm coming to save the day
our supports get out alive and I'm here to save everyone I'm
so sad Listen you you were asking for that I was good I was
good I don't know about you I'm getting healed I'm fine
he's actually one he's actually one please
there's an honor up there okay nice good job oh look the one
heal of the day on that guy hog trying to touch him under
we're gonna kill him yes wait where's he on yeah we did it
yeah he sounds like a little he sounds like a fucking
chihuahua Uphill bat Yeah, that felt like an uphill bat That
kid was the uphill That kid was the uphill That yeah, that
child Was definitely an uphill Don't beat me, the chihuahuas
I'm barking Don't bite Bro Bro Doki roasting him in chat a
fucking course I'm roasting him in chat you guys fucking 15
minute of the thing is like he knows Ruben I'm pretty sure
he knows like I avoided him I avoided him and reported him
but like the thing is he knows Ruben and was streaming so
I'm pretty sure like he was like he was like trying to do
like like um I guess like attention attention horror out to
Ruben's I'm a bigger streamer.
So that's his reputation now
He made himself look like a fucking fool All right,
here we go Damn he played himself.
He's just a bait streamer Point at him alive.
We don't have that guy on our team.
Let's go kid child That's unfortunate.
He was pretty good He was pretty Like, I was yapping, but
I'm way too much I liked, okay, it was pretty funny, or
Cassie You guys were having a good conversation, I don't
know The Cassie was like, I don't know, I'm getting healed,
bro Alright, that's what it seemed like And he'll never know
That was my favorite part When, like, uh When the Cassie
was, like, backing Me up, it was like, I'm getting healed,
bro, I don't know And so
all right oh no i might go here go yeah oh my god he got
burned so fucking fast i'm scared of getting hooked i'm
scared of getting hooked go back oh okay nice
nice he got genji wait they get to play merchant and like oh
wait we We have a mercy.
Whoa, where's our fucking hog?
Oh, there he is.
Here's our hog.
No hook.
Big.
Wait, their mercy is intake.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
We're fine.
That was me.
That mercy was...
How?
How the fuck does he have...
Oh.
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
No!
I'm about to go Kiriko.
Goodbye.
Cassidy, goodbye.
Goodbye, Cassidy.
Oh.
Oh, no.
Hog and just now got hooked.
That's okay.
They're gonna have Hog ult, I'm pretty sure.
Genji maybe might get Blade in like one more fight.
Because like, I swear I've not seen the fucking Genji
anywhere.
Oh shit, go go go go go go go!
Go go go!
Go!
Oh, not go, go, go, go, go, go.
I go.
Why are we ignoring the creed?
I go now.
That's what I meant by go.
I'm going Kiriko.
I'm Kiriko time.
I'm giving up on Ana.
Because we need cleanse.
We need the cleanse.
And we're killing this guy.
How the fuck?
The.
The hog is scary.
Cassidy, Cassidy, please.
Cassidy, no.
I'm trying!
It's always Kirko time.
I've never been so confident that we're winning a game than
right now.
now they really wanted me i even climbed i even climbed the
wall i don't understand where is there's like three
different things i heard yeah they pop so many ults i
climbed to avoid the castle just to get shot down just to
get slashed just get shanked by by Genji.
That's on the wrong part of the neighborhood.
Can't climb your way out of this.
I have to play Kiriko for the cleanse.
This sucks.
This is what happens when they have an honor and we don't.
How do you do this?
Alright, here we go.
This is it.
What?
Oh my god.
God, she missed her anti.
She's just like me.
Oh, God.
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please,
please.
No, she's not.
It's fine.
Who's healing the mercy?
Good question.
Honestly.
Oh, Toglo!
Yes!
I contributed.
I contributed to this.
Wait, oh no, oh no, the hog's back.
You're by yourself over there.
That's okay.
Is it okay?
Please, please heal.
Please heal me, please.
I can't, I can't heal you.
I'm fucking with our hog.
No, we cannot.
We cannot.
Our poor Cassidy begging for the heals.
we were all we were all tunnel version on the hog honestly
it was in fact not okay we're all spread out all right there
we go it's fine this is fine we're so healthy we're so
healthy this is good this is not good this is not good no
I'm okay.
They're gonna res, aren't they?
They're gonna res.
I fucking knew it.
I fucking called it.
I- What?
We had 20 people!
Nobody looked at the hog!
Okay.
No mercy!
Two.
Okay.
there we go all i'm saying is that we had 20 people and
nobody looked at the hog i think he got hooked by 20 people
he kill hog now i'm not there i'm here now i need to save my
cleanse for him okay i lived these you do i told no oh thank
god okay thank god okay it's Nothing to worry about.
Nothing to worry about.
He missed his hook.
See?
Recreate half.
He doesn't have hook.
As long as I don't look at him.
We'll be fine.
He doesn't have hook again.
Oh god.
There you go.
There you go!
We're fine!
Big.
Okay, I'm just pushing up his top leg.
Okay.
Nice.
See?
Everything's fine.
he's so low Cassidy's right here where the fuck is the
Cassidy oh there's the Cassidy what the fuck what was he
doing in that corner oh god oh they didn't touch they didn't
touch we're okay
you can't hook if you don't look exactly if you don't look
at where you don't look at the hog you never get hooked
that's the gamepad i told you my kyrko's not that bad don't
look at the accuracy
see it's not that bad it's all right i have to play kyrko
for cleanse unless kira go exactly no no no don't look at
look at oh my god don't look at the heels though oh my god
don't look at the heels oh it's just whoa
if you don't look they don't see all right let's see where
are they at we'll be fine you know i have a plan i don't
like this plan already
Oh!
Yes!
Oh, keep him up!
Keep him up!
Oh, they got the res.
They got the res.
And then he got the hook!
Where's this bullshit?
Oh, no.
I'm fucking dead.
What?
I'm fucking...
Yeah, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
if you guys every time i hear let's hear a plan i knew it
was not gonna be good it's never good when you hear let's
hear a plan i had a feeling guys i had a feeling
all right i am heading to our hog i am heading to our hog Oh
my god.
Cleanse!
This is it!
I saved my cleanse for that one moment!
The one streamer moment!
I did it.
What?
Alright, I'm resing.
I'm resing.
I should not do that.
I could have got hooked.
I almost got hooked there.
Bad rush.
Oh god.
No!
Please, go let them flip it!
Do not let them flip it!
Hit your shots!
The soldier didn't hit the shots.
Oh my god, I'm anti-knife, I can't.
Not like this.
Don't get hooked!
No, he doesn't hook.
He has no hook.
See?
Ana, please.
Ana, he can jump back up.
They can jump back up.
Ana, please.
Please.
He knows how to jump.
Ana, no!
No!
He's one?
Ana, why would you be there?
They know how to jump!
There you go.
Don't say it's over!
Don't say it, guys!
It can't be over yet!
Maybe I'm just an Ana bot.
Maybe I'm just an Ana one trick, you know?
Because...
I could just be an Ana one trick at this point.
I feel like I've had more success as Ana.
I can't believe it.
I do better when I'm on Ana than any other character.
Alright, no more getting picked.
Yeah.
Whoever gets picked, we blame for the entire game.
Oh god, I'm gonna run away.
I'm gonna be here.
I'm gonna position myself away from everybody.
Alright.
Feels like sunlight, huh?
I'm going to not keep the attack.
Yeah, I'm going to save my cleanse for our aunties.
No hinder.
Ooh.
Don't die, guys.
Whoa.
You're doing that thing.
Oh, no more.
Dropping and dropping and dropping.
You're dropping.
But our DPS needs help.
I'm on point with Hogg, by the way.
Oh, God.
Wait, what the fuck?
No way!
Daughter!
I had just thought my Ana's got this!
This is winnable.
No, you actually should be winnable.
I come back to him.
Oh, God.
Really good today.
Alright.
Oh, my God!
We still have one more fight, though, guys.
We still have one more fight, and he's on Doomfest, and he's
not in Orville.
Okay.
There's still one more fight.
I gotta keep our...
I gotta keep our DPS alive.
I'll do him half.
Praise on me.
This is fine.
Cleanse!
Alright, no throwing.
Got you!
I got you!
It's so winnable!
I'm just that good!
We did it!
I fucking knew it.
It's not me.
It was never me.
The combat.
It was never my fault.
Bro, fuck that kid.
That kid.
He lives right free in my mind right now.
Bitch, I hope you keep losing SR!
Fuck that child!
That's right, I don't need you!
Dude, it was the Chihuahua.
It was the fucking Chihuahua.
I think my favorite thing about your dick is how he's not an
orb.
And as thank you for the super chat that you can think, you
know what that's my favorite thing too i think you're right
the fact that like he's not an orb and i can actually see my
tank does makes so much of a difference in video games it's
actually crazy gem thank you for the one gift the chip thank
you thank you that damn fucking chihuahua
yay here we go is it zen time zen time Yay!
Because I don't want to play Kiriko!
How you guys doing?
I don't want to play Kiriko!
What's up?
I'm ready to bunch to meet you nowadays.
Let's make sure we kick all the fucking band of the pillars.
Boom.
I wish Blizzard World was real.
Is anybody else here up with me?
no okay guys i could oh no they have a one went on i'm gonna
leave they have a went on and a mora oh that's scary
actually oh and a hanjo all right i'm gonna back up a little
bit they have like a lot of characters that can actually
like poke me and i'll die which i am not a huge fan of i'm
gonna keep that strong you guys why monkey sleeping
Guys, I think I'm gonna I'm gonna leave now No, no, no, we
actually win these I'm gonna leave now I am Is he gonna
touch?
Okay I couldn't touch But I did my best I almost killed him
Thank you, my hero It's fine.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Guys, all I'm saying when I die, I might pick a character.
Yeah!
That's fucking right now if I Oh, shit!
Okay, I didn't get headshot.
That's the thing.
Thank God.
I didn't get headshot, guys.
Okay.
They have to, like, go here, right?
Like, I might...
I'm fine.
I'm okay.
Oh, he is not.
No!
They went out of!
They went out!
Anna and Diva!
Wait, Diva's sleeping?
It's fine.
I had to die.
It was just canon.
No!
They went Anna!
Let's fucking cleanse this badass again!
No!
Every time!
I got my one.
Every fucking time!
I have to fucking...
I have to...
Oh my god, I know.
Okay, you won't be able to do anything with that?
Oh, no.
There we go.
We're fine.
I'm gonna be fine, though, with this Genji on my ass.
It's okay.
Back to Kiri.
jail I go.
You thought you could leave the Kiriko jail.
Look, I'm playing Kiriko.
Guys, it's because I need to up my win rate on Kiriko, okay,
guys?
This is the only reason.
No.
Oh, no.
Please.
Please don't log me.
Just play.
Please.
I don't want to just play.
Just blade.
Don't force this off of me.
Thank you.
Blade.
Do the blade.
There you go.
I got you!
I don't got you.
It's here.
Guys, I don't got you anymore!
Guys, I don't got you.
It's here go time.
And back to Kierko Jel, I go.
Back to Kierko, Jel, I go.
I love Kierko.
Woo!
I love being Kierko.
Yeah!
Yeah, cleanse time!
It's time to cleanse!
Time to cleanse all those aunties!
Let's go!
Okay, I need to save my new save my cleanse for it.
More no fate.
Oh, he ate it!
What's the point of cleansing?
Oh my god!
What's the point of cleansing if he just eats it?
Oh my god, I hope it was at least delicious.
Oh my god.
Guys.
Please.
Okay.
Thank guys.
It's okay, they couldn't eat that.
What?
Okay, here I go.
Here I go.
Woo!
Okay, we needed maybe a Zarya there.
We need maybe for Zarya Symmetra.
That's, um, honestly could have gone worse.
We just do better on offense.
It's okay.
We'll do better on offense, right?
Jesse, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thanks for reading my super chat early.
I'm backing out.
Good luck on Masters.
It's okay.
As long as I'm throwing other people's top 500 games, I'm
fine with that.
As long as I'm give it and take it, hundreds from people,
I'll be fine.
We're an offense team.
We're an offense team, guys.
This is it.
We're just an offense team.
This was our legacy.
This was what we're meant to play as.
Like, we were just meant to be...
We were just meant to be, Kyrko.
We must all be in the cause with fighting for here we go
that's fine don't mean that guy i was born for this i was
born for this i hope i hope somebody loses their top 500 in
this game stay sharp it's harder to keep you alive when
you're distracted here we go This is it.
I believe.
Yay!
Alright.
I caught the anti- Oh, wait!
Wait!
If he plays...
If he plays fucking Zarya, I wouldn't have to!
We should just win this for three.
Yeah, we should.
Exactly.
That's how it should go, yes.
We got the best player.
Our Ana's okay.
Our Ana's so healthy.
Look at that.
See?
I knew we were in...
I knew we were in an offense team.
Okay, I'm gonna fucking cap.
They don't need heals.
They don't need heals, guys.
We're five.
All I'm saying is that now that we have Zarya, I don't need
to play.
I don't need to play Kierko anymore.
Because the Zarya bubbles is our cleanse.
We have tank cleanse.
So I can play whatever I want.
Oh my god.
Counterpicking!
How dare you counterpicking my Overwatch games?
You're all supposed to one trick a hero.
And they're hanzos alone bottom right.
This fucking sucks.
Yo, okay, guys, I changed my mind.
I need help.
I need you.
My hero.
Okay.
I'm doing this to stay alive.
Okay, I...
There you go.
I'm dead.
No!
It's okay, guys.
It's okay, I have a rush.
divan counterswap their tank again oh my god i can't believe
people are countering each other this is not the overwatch i
remember where are my one tricks on the enemy team but not
my team though not on my team no no no no i can't even use
my fucking rush because like where are we rushing We can
force pride.
He's low Woo, please That's fine for five.
Oh, we're not fine.
Oh Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, that's actually
pretty awkward That's pretty awkward.
All right, we are You can nano me this fight and I can just
like dive somebody.
All right, we're gonna We're gonna play.
Okay, but like, hear me out.
Hear me out.
What if we play?
What if we play Brig?
Hear me out.
I barely play Brig, but like, I think I can take him on.
Oh my god, we almost see nine.
They almost see nine.
They have Primal.
Nope.
I'm gonna distract them in the hunt.
Oh, never mind.
Oh!
Okay, I hit those.
Okay, I hit Suzu's.
Oh, this is where we died.
This is where we died.
This is where we die.
I'm going big.
Fuck this.
Hear me out.
This will work.
Guys, hear me out.
This will 100% work.
Hear me out.
I am going to fucking counter them so fucking hard.
watch this I did it I told you I swapped brig and then I did
it I countered the win ton it was that easy oh my god it was
actually that easy are we are none of us on the cart like
none of us went on the
went on the cart.
That's actually crazy.
Alright.
Remember when I said I'm going to counter the win-thun?
I did not predict a ult.
Okay.
I can't stop a fucking monkey ult.
That's all I'm saying.
I'm all I'm saying.
I can't stop a monkey ult.
Alright, okay, hear me out.
What if I swap this?
Okay, I can't swap.
I should build an ult first.
I'm gonna build this ult first, and then we'll swap.
Monkey too strong.
It was just unlucky.
I'm gonna protect this Ana, though.
I'll protect people.
Don't worry.
I'll protect my team.
I'm gonna fall scarred.
I'll be here with Yonkart.
Oh shit.
Please.
Oh.
Oh no.
Please.
I thought the auto wouldn't look at me.
It's okay.
Guys.
It's okay, guys.
It's okay.
It was just...
Okay, maybe it's not okay.
Maybe it's...
Maybe it's not okay.
I shouldn't be swapping.
Look.
This is it.
Morris the pick.
The plan isn't working.
I realized that like maybe I need to know how to play break
to play break It's definitely not okay
I feel like I need to know how to play break to play break I
don't play break is that is that obvious Is it obvious that
I don't play break I can't tell Oh my god bro this fucking
this monkey has been changed bro Please, please, please.
Alright.
Oh my god.
This fucking monkey has been chasing me this entire time.
Really?
Not obvious.
Oh my god.
Yeah, the monkey was so good.
I can't believe it.
You know what?
It was an equal.
fair match the monkey absolutely fucking hated me i swear i
was getting targeted i swear this was targeted harassment i
can't believe it it was targeted i refuse to believe it was
it it was not me
ban him for targeted harassment.
That one's done this like strongest dokey hater.
He's an anti.
I can feel it.
I can feel the anti in him.
Alright.
See, I'm on now.
I'll be on on one trick.
Yay!
Alright.
Avoid that teammate i can't even get him as my teammate
because i'm duoed with a team yo yo how you guys doing this
is gonna hit something yo so um was this wide cute for you
this is diamond too oh okay oh just just just asking because
a little birdie told me a little birdie told you why that
your tank might be white cute what did What the fuck?
What does he mean by that?
Yeah, you know.
Okay, it's waiting.
Ooh, anti!
Huge!
Oh, they have a widow!
Oh, my God!
Oh, my God.
She's so loud, though.
Holy shit.
Her mic is, like, peaky.
I'm leaving.
Goodbye.
Not goodbye.
I might have to mute her mic is so fucking loud
the mic was so loud
okay we're fine we're fine oh my god i can't i can't deal
with i can't do who my webcam likes.
I died!
I did it!
I need a reload.
We're doing it.
Hey!
Look at that.
We're five.
Where's the cast?
We're doing it!
Yay!
Oh.
mercy she's so low please shoot him oh my god the double
hook though that's actually gamer right there soldier is
scared i know my one trick don't be scared i'm here to
protect you i can do this oh my god yep gamers
We're a gamer experience right there.
There's so just one bottom right.
He's outside.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, we're gonna roll a ring around the rosy this.
The Cassie and I were just Did you like the cast that has
ring around the rosy?
It works!
Oh, no, no, no.
Doom absolutely dies.
He has no block.
They have no suzu.
Please.
Please hide.
No!
It actually works.
Alright.
That's fine.
Wait, did he alt it?
No, he did it.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
How did she live so long?
It's called positioning.
You see that spray?
That's how I live that long.
That's how I live.
Copy.
Oh my god, four aunties.
I don't know if you guys saw that, but I had auntied four
people just said
He ended guys, I think he ended.
Oh no I'm a little scared though Can we can we know?
Oh no
I couldn't see!
There was red everywhere!
I couldn't see him!
Guys, alright, watch this.
Five anties right there.
No, six anties.
Because I'm going to treat...
My anties can transcend back to Overwatch 1.
You see that?
I just antied five people.
I'm coming back.
I have the ult.
Oh my god, they're like...
barely alive here oh my god i'm gonna meet shield you guys
oh i can't meet you guys
no bro i how do i travel yo what okay they just i'm i'm the
only person here you're the only one alive no i'm not but
why are they using fucking 80 old yeah that line all right
okay here you go this is it oh my god she had i don't even
have to look to anti that's how good i am i don't care if
they go somewhere i fucking beat the shit out of that guy
it's that easy okay nice nice nice
Please, please, I'm getting harassed!
Please!
Alright, we're okay.
Oh god!
Goodbye, goodbye!
Are you talking about the aunties or your aunties?
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you, right?
Alright, we're okay.
See, we're okay.
Yo, you also sound like you're using a webcam mic.
Why are you talking?
You lose your right to talk if you have webcam mic.
Okay.
Oh.
Ring around a Rosie.
Ring around.
please please get no you don't even you didn't even get okay
you killed him all right get me back to 21 god holy it's
okay i have a altar a little yuki no it's not my fault hi
boom exactly look at our dps look at our dps they have
negative killed kd the negative kd let's make our not us oh
don't let them push don't let them push don't let them push
go go go go oh not go for me though we lost the lead though
it's fine that we let them cap there you go we're going
we're going as hard as we can go okay that's not whoa please
don't please don't harass me oh god if i keep rubin up
everything will be fine please he's literally won okay
I how How I'm fucking anti this man 20 hundred times
It's because they hate v-tubers this is targeted you can
tell This is 100% targeted What are they gonna do to me?
There's no way
I swear to God I swear I swear who gave him a hundred punch?
who look at him his punch is at a hundred all right fellas
need a lot who gave this to him
okay no you need to say okay with a little more enthusiasm
there you sound bro i'm funky look at our dps 7 versus 24
that guy sucks 7 versus 24
Somebody's not picking it up and by somebody I met everybody
except for me and Ruben
I don't trust my DPS enough to like give them heal give them
nano like she did zero
what the foot wait there was a murky here really low team
dude yeah our team got dipped hard that's a hard avoid no i
can't avoid people i assume i assume like uh i assume like i
don't No, Ruben will avoid them for me.
Alright, this is it.
Yeah, the Ninja Mercy out of nowhere.
Guys, we're not gonna win this.
I'm sorry.
I...
I don't think this is winnable.
I'm gonna lie.
Yeah, yeah, we lost two.
Yeah.
We lost...
Ruben we're we're doing everything we can to keep you alive
Ruben
I I knew that wasn't one of the I you have late game guys no
amount of healing can save a 9 to 12 and 9 to 13 no amount
of healing can save this fucking team The negative DPS Both
healers have 11k plus healing We can't save a fucking stupid
DPS player The healer, yeah the DPS diff was Was just
It's just not it It's just not it It's just not it They
just...
It's just not it, guys.
It was just not it.
That's Overwatch matchmaking for you?
Yeah.
Oh, nice.
I avoided those people.
Alright.
Guys, I get one game where I can relax.
Guys, this is my one.
Guys, I can relax now.
It'll be fine.
I won't fuck around.
I won't troll.
I won't troll chat.
For reals.
Yeah, queues are fast.
I mean, it's prime time.
This was me, guys.
Look, see?
It sets the sun sets.
This was when I used to be good.
This was when people wouldn't target me because I was a
V-tuber.
Alright.
The old animated sprays.
Guys, I'm only losing.
I'm only losing because people are targeting me.
Say no now.
I used to win because I wasn't a V-tuber back then.
be nicer to me.
It's true.
Okay.
It's true, guys.
Oh my god, it's another...
Oh god, it's another doom.
I might have...
No!
I got a pick here.
Oh god.
Oh god, please.
I have 20 people on me.
Bro, what is going on?
Why is there so...
Why do we have another...
Why is every...
Oh, Sombra for Doom.
Okay, I was going to say, why is everybody playing Sombra?
And I realized Doom.
Doom.
I'm going, Diva.
You just got to beat up the back line.
All right, here we go.
Honestly, he's going to get a kill.
I can...
I believe.
Sombra, if you can touch, I can follow up.
Never mind, never mind.
He's not going to touch, man.
I don't think he can make it.
Let's say, there's no way.
There's no way he makes it is.
And we got a pick, though.
Whoa!
Look at him go!
See?
So fucking easy.
Please don't die.
Oh, please don't!
Guys, I told you, every time, every time I get a little bit
confident, Doomfist is here to punch me like slam me to the
floor easy i got doomed i got fucking doomed man i hate this
the world isn't fair playing a brush too made me realize the
world just isn't fair the world is just unfair oh bro i
think she had oh my god i think she wanted to stick me
there's no way That was 100% a stick.
Oh my god.
There's no way.
Oh, well, well, there is a way now.
There is a way.
Really one.
Oh, please grab your mech.
Get your mech.
Please get your mech.
That's all I want.
Get your fucking mech.
Whoa!
Here go, don't die!
But also heal me!
I'm swapping.
I can't relax.
There's no relaxing in this game.
There's just no relaxing in this game, guys.
Alright, back to being my one trick.
Back to one tricking.
Here we go.
In the mech, Ruben.
Back to my one trick.
Doom on me, no block.
It's fine.
We can kill Doom.
He's half HP alone.
Ruben, please.
me please speak me and please don't speak me in a way where
i could die all right i'm dead the doom can still die look
at this guy he's happy with me look at him just look at him
for the love of god just look at him okay i'll really lead
back to anna hate it i got you kill zen please just look at
him i swear i did not get targeted this hard when i played
off stream i swear to god things were so much easier she's
really low oh my god leave me alone just leave me alone i
don't deserve this i've been a good person nice good kill
all right nice
He wanted to sticky me so badly.
Oh my god.
He was ready to sticky me.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Leave me alone!
Holy shit!
I literally... I can't breathe!
Leave me alone!
Kill him!
Just kill him!
I swear dog!
This is where I die.
Ring around.
Come on, pass.
Half left.
Thank you.
Kill Zen.
It's okay.
Thank you.
Somebody kill this man!
Please, he's solo.
He's solo.
She...
Please.
Can I cross?
Do I have enough time to cross?
I'm walking in a straight line.
Please don't headshot me.
Oh, no.
Oh, no!
Leave me alone!
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
We're fine.
He's just acting fully.
It's fine.
We're okay.
We're okay, guys.
Nothing to worry about.
Let me live!
Please!
Please, for the love of God!
Oh my god, I see him!
I see him!
I see him and I hear the tracer!
Let me live!
Go ahead.
Oh god.
That's fine.
Got my tool?
You win those, they don't have res.
That's good.
They just have Mercy, Zen, and Doom.
You win that.
DMV activated.
Oh my god, please.
Kill Mercy.
Oh my god, just kill the Zen.
Kill the Zen!
When you're getting...
Okay, anybody can't be afraid of Doom the way I was being
treated.
The bully is back.
Oh my god.
If you saw what I was...
You guys saw literally what I was going through.
You guys saw the targeted hate.
Oh my god.
This is it.
I'll be okay.
I'll be okay guys.
I'll be okay this time.
There's no way.
Report.
I will not leave a broken world behind.
Wait, which one's?
Stay sharp.
It's hard to keep you alive when you distract it.
But...
A mother's wife.
Your work is never done.
You're right, good thinking guys.
Good thinking.
Fuck that dude.
It's coming.
Oh my god, they have a Symmetra.
Oh my god, he's on fire.
Oh, no.
Oh, we got Zenyata.
We got Zenyata.
He's anti.
I swear to God.
I swear, please.
Please don't let him live.
I got my two.
All right, we're fine.
Ash, they have no supports.
We're okay.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God.
Worst in your previous kit.
I'm okay that rock needed an ante oh thank god okay our
somber is actually shutting him down that makes me a lot
happier knowing that knowing that it's working nice we're
doing it we're doing it all right we're doing it everything
is fine
oh thank god guys guys he left me alone now he's targeting
He's eating Sombra!
He has a new person to hate!
Guys, that wall was so...
That wall needed healing.
You guys don't understand.
Guys, I panicked Naded.
I couldn't help it.
I panicked.
It was so scary.
You don't understand.
Holy shit.
He almost burned to death.
I literally got it just in time.
Wait, is that junk rat?
No, that wasn't.
That was just doom.
Oh, GG's.
Oh, thank God.
He stopped.
Guys, he stopped.
He stopped going for me.
Oh, my God.
The constant hack is actually ring around the rosy ring
around the rosy.
Is that guy of all people talking shit to his teammates?
No!
Guys, the moment I stopped ring-arounding the rosy, it was
over.
I was like, maybe I don't need a ring-around the rosy, you
know?
Maybe I was confident in being like, the Doomfist is not
aiming for me, clearly.
For one moment, I was like, he's not aiming for me.
But he never forgets.
die is he gonna die did he did he totally die i couldn't
tell i i can't tell do you think he totally dies oh god oh
god oh all right so instead of like the doom targeting me
now it's like everybody else everybody else sending in is
sending in a a kill list good job gg i think this is the
worst part of being supported everybody just wants to kill
you we did it yay who's the zen yada did he fucking
advertise his twitch and then people We're like, avoid this,
and yada.
We're afraid of.
A 30k bounty.
Alright.
Who do I?
I got this Zen and Sim.
Okay.
Who do I avoid?
Alright.
I'm going to cleanse my avoids list.
Give me a sec.
Let me cleanse my avoids list.
I'm hiding the game so I don't put...
I don't put the void list on blast.
Okay.
No, I can't!
Okay, unavoid.
Alright.
Let's see.
Now traveling to prepare for battle.
Select your hero.
I say as like, I was like, oh I don't want to blast, put
somebody on blast.
I say as I fucking shit talked like 20 different people from
this stream alone.
Is it time?
Is it...
Alright, here we go.
is it oh we have we have a we have a junk rat that's fine
not leave a broken world behind they say it's okay it's fine
it's fine you think we can get we can climb here i know more
than anyone we can do this is an easy target yeah we'll be
fine everything will be fine
Yo yo yo, I mean you tell he's a fucking specialist look at
his gold gun.
Look at my honestly you can farm a gold gun in so fast
I have a new lorry.
Oh my god
All right, he's gonna Good fit.
Ow.
Oh How?
Nice.
All right, we're good.
Oh, thank God.
Wait.
We take those.
Yay!
Free!
Free point!
It's okay.
This next ante, watch this.
Watch this next ante.
Oh!
They never expected!
I told you!
Oh shit!
There is people there.
We need SOS.
SOS right now.
Guys?
You'll never expect the Spanish Inquiation.
Inquisition?
Inquisition.
They're on as low.
Okay.
I'll probably live, I'm fine.
There you are.
Orion is coming in.
Oh, I hit those!
Inquisition?
Inquisition.
Yeah!
You never expected.
Oh, I hear him.
I hear him on the right.
Three aunties.
Oh shit!
Ryan, Ryan, Ryan, Ryan!
Ryan, Ryan, Ryan!
Oh shit!
Please!
Where is he going?
What is he doing?
What is this, what is this gameplay?
They're Moira's really low coast.
I don't think they know I'm here.
Ah!
I'm alive.
We did it!
Yay!
Yippee!
I saw my life flash before my eyes, but we're okay!
We're okay!
I didn't even like, no.
I didn't even have to use my hook.
I don't think they know why Mirza Ryan tries to pin.
Here we go.
Can we see that?
Yoki is having her toxic guys the thing is playing overwatch
no matter how pma you are When you're playing overwatch
you're there's no way to be positive in overwatch
There's no way to be positive about anything when you're
playing overwatch
Fine We can get mad we can get back masters here PMA
streamers are not even PMA they're just passive aggressive
like it's just a fact they're not actually positive they're
just extremely passive aggressive
it's true whoa who is he trying to kill our junk rat our
junk rat bro I don't even know who I'm trying to kill
oh please please it's so winnable hog just keep healing
you're a hog you have regen he's so dead our team was not
ready to help why is this guy typing at me guys please i
don't want to be on point alone guys guys please
I'm sorry, I saw the charge.
I saw the charge and I freaked out.
Nice.
Got my one.
Why is nobody on point?
he has to either shadow me or the larry he has to pick he
has to pick one or the other and he picked neither okay not
gonna lie though like i got so much fucking all charge from
that
oh god i'm backing out where's our fucking uh oh my god he
lives Please, I don't want to get shattered, please.
I don't want to get shattered.
Somebody, somebody, come over here!
Go, go!
I believe.
You versus Ryan!
There you go.
He just, yeepee.
Please don't shatter me.
This Ryan is not playing the game right now.
Ryan is not playing the game.
That poor Ryan.
Holy shit.
That run is having the worst time of his life.
This poor guy.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I panicked slept!
He's anti, please!
He's anti, just... He has the shadow.
You are me!
He has the shadow.
He missed!
Fuck!
Okay.
He missed Fighting his demons The right that replays the
game He actually missed What a fucking loser He's blaming
his teammate again Ryan watch Wait this is playing the game
Wait That's so sad Wait that's sad that's so sad i see the
saddest game ever guys we just guys i think it's possible we
just need to win three games in a row and then we can do it
we just need we just need three games in a row okay this is
it three games in a row we got this
i'm top 500 i'm gonna make actually no i can't make him lose
top 500 because i actually i wait i'm gonna avoid her junk
rat like bro like i'm sorry but like even though we won the
game it's not because of our junk rat there's there's no
it's not it's definitely not because of our junk it's
okay guys it's okay if you know i i have 50 games guys you
know why because i tried to speedrun the masters before the
stream because i there's account started off as like diamond
i mean it is diamond now but it was a lower it start this
account started off as d4 after placements and i tried to
speed run to masters before the stream but it didn't work i
i didn't speed run all right here we go
all right it's okay It's okay.
This is our new speed run now.
This is our new speed run.
It also, like, did it help that during the speed run, I was
only playing late night queues?
I was only...
It was only...
Imagine an Anna one trick.
I'm not even a one trick!
I can perfectly play other heroes!
Anna is the most fun and also, like, my best one.
Chunk for Torb.
Torb is okay.
It's like an extra player.
It's like having, like, six players.
Guys, it doesn't help that would play this game.
I like late night cues.
And, like, late night cues are absolutely the most terrible
thing you can ever play on.
What?
Muchaloo.
Okay, this is where I die, most likely.
unless I don't die because I'm a gamer it's okay I'll do
something eventually give me a sec oh they used Susu again
there you go see alright I gotta hide look at that another
Susu okay let's hope he doesn't die because he doesn't
because he's gaming gamer of the your fucking course well
thank you easiest game of my life we're gonna 2-0 them right
here I'm gonna bet on it I'll bet like $100 that we're gonna
2-0 them look at that and the anti who is she even though
like like a top 500 Anna should be able to anti anything but
like who is she
oh shit It's okay.
We can...
Alright, I'm gonna back out.
I don't think we're gonna win this.
I don't think...
Wait, they're running?
Sigma?
That's cheating!
Oh, I'm gonna die.
No, you're not!
I'm a fucking healer!
No, I'm not the Sigma.
I can't...
I hate playing on against Sigma.
This is it.
Wait.
This guy died!
No, he doesn't I've never seen someone more one HP in my
life.
Oh, no, please please please please please please please I
had to back off he was This is not perfect Okay, he just
gave him like 100 HP, but that's okay Oh my god, that poor
Sigma got cyber bullied so hard
No, shoot the dwarf it would be so funny beautiful oh no
that that sleep would have hit if the sigma didn't have
shield it would have hit 100% fucking hell wait is that okay
we're fine everything's fine i got the capacity too for that
i'm saying is that because i'm a support any any kills my
dps gets is my kill It's the rule of law.
Who is he ulting?
Oh, our poor fucking torb.
Wait, more than no fade.
We can kill Sig.
Oh!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Not the shield, not the shield.
No, you suck your fat ass took the anti!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Cassidy, take the hit for me.
Cassidy, take the hit.
take the hit Cassidy I cannot contest right now give me a
sec it's okay I'll contest for us I'll punch him sorry Torr
intentional body block by the way very intentional I'm body
blocking for the other team
that's okay See?
2-0.
Alright, who wants to bet?
We're gonna 2-0 with them.
Guys, I don't have a problem with betting.
He wanted the healing.
Yay, yippee!
How are we overwatching?
I think we're like solid even at the moment.
If we win one more game, we're positive.
It only took us three hours.
We went through a lot.
If we win one more game, we have a positive win rate.
It just takes one game.
Oh my god, I'm living life by the edge.
Oh, they have a Zen.
Oh no, not a Zenyada.
Only took three hours to break even.
It's just business.
Okay, that's not fair.
Like I'm being shot at.
That's not fair.
It's okay.
I am also being shot at.
Oh no.
Oh wait, he's alive?
Wait, he's alive?
How the fuck is he alive?
Oh, I got you.
I got you.
I have to reload.
How are we alive?
Nice!
This game is so trash.
Yes, but what else do I have left?
Like, what was it?
Marvel Rivals waiting room right now.
This is my...
This is the waiting room for the Marvel shooter game.
They have a hog now.
Okay, they know I'm here.
There's the sniper.
and you know shit really all i'm saying is that if you had
streamermost don't worry they won't know i'm right here like
right here they will not know they will not look down watch
watch oh he turned around he turned around i told you they
don't know they wouldn't never know i told you i knew they
wouldn't know
oh god oh god he's coming over wait what the what is a
soldier doing why is a soldier doing it our fucking honor
get Get killed like that.
What the fuck?
Why did he jump down from the top wall?
Wait, where was my bodyguards?
That was my first day!
I hope the Cassidy dies in game.
I don't mind.
We should all be one, one, one, one, one.
All right.
This is so unchanging.
Okay.
That's fine.
Yes, it's perfect vibe.
This is not fine anymore.
I would have...
Okay, all I'm saying is that I could have actually 100%
killed the cure girl with just my shame.
No, the castle didn't live!
Press all the cues.
I don't know how I lived there.
Guys, we got a positive win rate.
We were here.
guys we were here a positive win rate the dokey luck is real
i can't believe it for today we got a positive win rate for
today oh my god i just need two more wins it's so possible
it's like it's oh my gosh it's so winnable i i believe in us
there's no way it's not like we're gonna lose like five
games in a row guys it will take me like i bet you in four
hours in four hours we can we can we can finally have a
positive win rate
this is it i believe okay i'll tell i'll let you guys see
how bad how bad my win rate is oh yeah i see it's actually
pretty up it's it's pretty bad this is this is my most
played it for this season it's pretty bad it's it's really
bad okay
Speaking of Kiriko.
Actually, I won't.
I don't want to play Kiriko.
I actually don't want to play Kiriko.
Bro, I hate this map so much.
I actually hate this map, like, so much.
I wish they would remove this map.
Okay.
21 and, like, three of them are right now.
I swear.
I swear it's not because of me, though.
Every time I lose as...
Every time I lose as Kierko, it's not me.
It was never me.
I swear.
I swear, guys.
It's never a me issue.
All I'm saying.
Here we go.
Yay.
I hate this map, though.
I hate this map so much.
Oh, it's not me.
It's my tank and DPS and other support.
Hey.
Hello.
We must strike them down.
Alright.
Wait.
I went the wrong way.
I'm sorry.
I don't know why I went this way.
My actual teammates are over here.
Oh, that's a good.
What the f- Where did the chunker game from?
Holy shit.
Where did he come from?
What the fuck?
They also have a slumber now.
Alright, this is a little awkward that we lost that.
We got the initial pick too!
Wait, I don't know if I saw it as the streamish mode name,
but like...
If it's not, then he's actually...
Oh, I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
Oh, I'm so scared.
I leave.
Guys, I might lose my positive win rate right here.
I have a plan.
I want to go under there.
I might lose.
Guys.
I'm following you.
There might be a moment where I lose my positive win rate.
Maybe.
It's possible.
And then he's...
Hold up.
Leave him.
Do we leave him?
Did we leave him?
I don't think we left him.
I don't think...
Please!
Me!
Cleanse!
I'm important!
This is still winnable.
Guys, I didn't get cleansed.
I didn't get... Guys, I didn't get cleansed.
I don't...
We're cleansed.
Are Kierkegaard only cleansed themselves?
See, this Kierkegaard looks like a person with a 29% win
rate.
Not gonna lie.
I bet you that Kierkegaard has a worse win rate than me on
Kierkegaard.
Oh, I was fucking around.
I was fucking around.
Why would a Samba be right there?
Why would she be right here?
Guys!
Like, why would she be right here?
Oh my god.
Like, how?
How are they like at her spawn?
Okay, here we go.
Just somber things.
I swear.
Target it.
100% target it.
There's no way.
There's no way it's not targeted.
I'm just gonna...
Go.
I'm dead.
No more go.
They're all low.
Oh my god.
Good kill.
I am going to go Zenyata.
What?
For the widow?
Did she just solo all together?
Yeah, for widow?
That's crazy.
That's kind of fucked up.
You bypassed it, wouldn't you?
It was nice having a positive win rate for a little bit,
though.
I had a good time with that.
It felt really good for, like, one second.
They're shaking's not top right now, which means we can go
top.
Oh, wait a second.
You got a touch.
Oh, that's the...
I didn't realize.
Ah, that's fine.
We weren't winning that fight.
Uh, all right.
I'm going to die.
Might as well.
I might as well.
Guys, no, I have an idea.
I have an idea.
I think they're chasing us.
This is it.
This is the plan.
This has to be the plan, right?
This is it.
There's no way.
It would be so funny if I get railed right here.
It would be so funny.
Two Chaos, two Chaos this is it!
I knew it!
I fucking knew this was the plan.
I miss the character.
I knew it.
How good are you?
I knew it guys.
This was the plan all along.
Me too.
All right.
All we have to do?
Make sure our widow is pocketed.
What the fuck?
Why is there three people here behind us?
Oh, they're just...
Oh, that's not good.
Yeah, this is not good at all.
This ends now.
It's fine.
It's not fine.
I was gonna say this is winnable.
It's not fine anymore.
Kiriko, it's not fine.
It's not fine at all.
No, Ruben, you are the only one left!
You know, I got a little ambitious.
No!
It's okay.
It'll be different here.
It'll be different, I believe.
I just realized how big I am on the screen.
I hope that has not been, like, the gameplay.
After three hours, I realized, whoa, I'm like one fourth of
the screen.
It's fine.
Oh, see the bubbles!
Make it bigger.
I got you!
Wait, okay, I got you.
Okay, all right.
That's fine.
We're fine.
Not quite.
We need it bigger.
Nice, we did it.
Woo!
That was a little ambitious.
They used EMP, they used Rush, they used Queen All.
That was very ambitious.
Go Bigger Go All.
I can't see shit and make it bigger.
oh oh there he is i'm a little scared just a little scared
just a little bit just a little bit
it's fine it's not fine anymore it is absolutely not fine
Famous last words.
Guys.
It was nice having it.
I think it was like...
It was pretty cool having a positive win rate, though.
It was pretty cool.
I...
I had a good time.
Seeing what that was like.
Dragon, think of the Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey, Doki.
How's it going?
I ordered Chipotle.
We were...
It was a reversal.
Are you fucking kidding me?
That shit was so rough.
That shit was so fucking rough.
And it was a fucking reversal.
That's actually crazy.
I worked so hard.
By the way, for those who don't know what reversal means,
reversal is basically our team was considered stronger than
the enemy team.
But there's no way.
I refuse to believe that.
Anyway, uh, but yeah, those are my stats.
It's a little...
It's not the best.
Welcome to Rialto.
Alright, here we go.
It's okay, we win this, we're back to positive.
Alright.
Guys, I know what to do.
Actually, no.
Actually, but like, what is...
I feel like what if This is how we break the curse I am
bronze player And the gameplay looked the same Actually
nanoblade Nanoblade, this is it Nanoblade Chrysal Oh shit
This guy doesn't heal This guy is a DPS Lucio This guy Okay
I'm gonna be doing all the healing here.
1,000.
Wait, who said that?
1,000 on Jokey losing?
Okay, Brados McGee.
I'm gonna remember you.
I'm gonna fucking call you out if we win this.
Why do I have this individual on my team?
What did I do to hurt God?
I'll just tell you.
This Lucio is a DPS Lucio.
So I'm gonna be doing all the healing soon.
here we go all right i have a ram watch this i'm gonna watch
i'm watching oh he's on time he's on time he's on time
there's i swear what there's no way okay i was gonna say i
understand this game right now if he lives i have to fix my
i have to fix my frames what what frames you're on lucio
people who have no Brains will play Lucio.
Hold on.
You want to do something crazy?
What?
Watch this.
In three.
Two.
I'll just...
I'm gonna...
Nice arc.
And tank?
You're gonna jump off the bridge from the altar, right?
No, I'm gonna make...
Oh, God.
Oh, God, please.
Wait, wait, wait.
That's okay.
You got the next one.
Got this.
All right.
I have to reload.
Okay.
In the tank, let's go.
Look at your tour.
But he is running.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
No!
No, stop doing streamer things.
I made space.
Stop doing streamer things.
My heart broke on the lamp.
Stop doing streamer things with the name.
Play the wind.
Don't play for streamer.
Streamer moments!
That's all I asked for!
We don't need streamer mode!
Cool streamer clips!
But the content...
The content is winning!
I try to play the best I can and I still make content.
That's just a fucking content diff right there.
I'm not seeing content diff.
But...
Content diff.
No, you're new.
Let's put like 400 ults right now.
Oh my god, the 2k!
We definitely do not.
Is the Bob there?
Is the Bob still there?
Oh my god.
Nice.
Now you do.
What?
I...
But my hog is just so...
It's okay.
So terrible.
We're good.
Oh my god.
One continent.
Let's jump here.
It's like a neon hog.
Literally neon hog.
Oh no.
They're making content.
They're trying to make content again.
I'm pushing the ash, bro.
Oh, what?
You're inting.
Oh wait.
No?
How does, how does me, how does me train the ash change this
way?
Bro, he got out junked.
Uh, watch this.
He got out junked so hard.
Keep watching.
I made space guys one day one day bring me back the days
when making content was winning the game bring me back to
the good old days not true it's like years of samba it's
just literally you and he's right please don't let me die
I'm your only hope gengu gengu please gengu please gengu
come on go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go
go go go go go go go go go go go go go go go please please
our gengu died with a nano blade our gengu died our lucia
died with the lucia
die too all right here we go here we not go all right i
think it's time no i don't think so it's all about the epic
fails when you close your ears
to be fair though if you're streaming this game non-stop you
have to you have to figure out some ways to make this
engagement engaging but then to be fair people watch shroud
and all the people there's an audience for people who just
want to watch winners i'm dead how did he find me oh okay i
saw that i was like how did he know okay there's still an
audience for people who want to watch people win games look
at shroud his personality is literally winning video games
and being good at video games oh i almost got the ram what's
shroud he's a he's a boomer that is good at any fps game he
touches and TPS game as well.
He's also a millionaire.
I hear you from Matra.
Okay, I gotta go.
Am I gonna die?
I'm dead to this.
I'm not dead to this.
That hero is so cringe.
We're fine.
We can do this.
I have ult.
It's crazy.
It comes to a win.
Alright, here you go.
It'll be fine.
We might have a junk rat, but we'll be fine.
Okay, I'm watching.
I'm watching.
Oh!
That's actually good!
That's actually a good bomb!
There you go.
We're doing it.
Is Doki winning?
winning being even in my win rate percentage right now for
today even after three and a half hours that'll be fine okay
to be fair any good gaming moment I remember whoa can't die
whoa why am I flying into I only remember that because I was
looking through old screenshots on my PC
I wish I kept my old I wish sometimes I kept my old videos
and old clips because I had a moment where I spawn can not
spawn can but like I I caused him the tatman to like rage so
hard in the game that like he he like rage quit overwatch no
I didn't keep any it was like on my old old PC I didn't keep
any of it because i never you know i never thought i would
have to look back at it again oh he's so dead you know it
was a good push i it was not winnable
the good old days i used to have clips of like moments where
like i have like big streamers rage at me because i was i
used to be good I...
It was like Tim the Tapman, Moon Moon, and...
Who is it?
It was like Tim, Moon, Moon, and one DPS player.
I don't remember who.
I wish I had the clips, though.
I wish I had the clips.
Always play Ramatra, right?
Okay, Zenyatta time.
All that lost content.
Yeah.
If I still had my tweets from, like, before a time, I would
have...
if i still have the clips we would or tweets from back then
then we could have it the lost media i wasn't a stream
sniper i wasn't a stream sniper it's just i queued up in
high elo games and they were in high elo games all i'm
saying go through my profile look my win right on every
other character yeah i would made tim the tatman rage quit
overwatch you like clearly got off game because of me he
even like solo shattered me too i was like fuck this lucio
all right buddy i'm gonna sit here and wipe my mouse down
while you yeah okay tim what are those names he tim the tab
man used to be like one of these streamers um on twitch and
that moomoo's just a gta rp streamer
Let's see.
You know they say like the camera adds 10 pounds?
I think picking hog out is like 40.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
I discreated him.
I think he wants to punch me now.
I personally think Doomfist dies.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Whoa!
I did that.
I did that smile.
Oh, I gave him punch.
I gave him punch.
Whoops.
He should die.
What?
No?
That's, that's, that's, that's a stupid, uh...
Oh, did I...
Okay, please get your mech.
Please get your mech.
That's all I want.
Oh, I didn't give a punch this time.
I didn't commit a mistake.
Oh.
I squished him.
Okay.
No, no, you don't.
Please, please.
Don't die.
You're welcome.
He's grateful.
Okay, buddy.
Please.
Guys, we need assistance!
Just kill one person!
That's all I care about!
A human is pushing it.
Thank you.
I'll take as a compliment.
Oh.
Guys.
Kill anything.
Like anything.
I'll take any kills.
Kill anybody.
Wait, nice, nice.
That's a good wall.
We got the bombs.
Bob down.
Putting my Bob in front of the enemy team's window.
is my favorite i have to save my chance for the mail what
rank is this v1 to master's three is the ring square and
they made it a garage door guys guys guys please where guys
if i die we lose where days if i die we lose all right nice
what are they doing square did mora i'm killing life
Oh, God, not hit anymore.
No!
Please, please kill them!
Please, just kill the doom!
Why is this guy still spying?
What are you doing?
Please just hit the doom.
You could have just died.
There you go.
We're fine.
It's okay.
We still have our...
still have transfer me a meal we're fine this is where I
might die though because the doom's looking at me oh I do
not like where I'm positioned right now ventures low under
wait he's what where is this it's okay it's okay it's not
okay because I'm so in this position now this is fine
I sacrificed my life for the position for that it was
actually not okay it was actually not okay
ow no Ruben if you if you dm the venture I want to let it oh
you didn't suck the venture would have died please nice not
sure not sure we're fine very cool wait what we're not fine
there's an adventure up there i was walled and i got full
venture combos and i had no answer it's okay capture lives
those the may also mister i know i saved that chance for 20
years just for the may to up her all no way i don't get
through this there's no way somebody break the thing oh my
god oh my god okay Thank you.
I don't know what that guy's doing, but...
I'd...
Mary go around, Mary go around, Mary...
What the fuck?
Okay.
Goodbye.
Oh,
shit.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
We can touch.
I will touch.
I can't play Bray.
Why Bray?
No, not the me!
Whoa!
I guess I'll die here.
This...
Okay, to be fair, we do have a junk player.
To be fair, guys.
We have a junk player.
Okay.
Oh my god, someone, please!
Break the wall!
I can't hear!
Oh no, oh no.
I'm gonna bomb you off.
Oh no.
He's so low!
Burn him!
Just kill him!
What the fuck is this wall?
Okay.
I'm actually mad.
We don't need to overchase.
They should be close to us.
Be careful.
More one, more one.
I almost have a rally.
I'm almost a rally.
Oh, I need care.
I need a rally.
I'm a rally.
I've rallied.
I've rallied one to stun.
Oh, oh my God.
I'm shooting the wall.
I'm coming.
I'm on the way.
I'm on their way.
Okay.
I have to reload.
We gotta kill Mayap, right?
No!
Me-wo, me-wo, me-wo, me-wo.
Me-wo, me-wo, me-wo.
Oh,
the Tyre Clutch!
They have May-O, though.
They have May-O.
I'm on one of those, I say, I say Kari.
Okay, big.
Oh, my God.
We only have, we only have Tectonic.
What did they use?
I thought, what, Meteor-Site, Tectonic, Lizard.
Oh, they should have both supports.
We just have tectonic.
We need to, we need to try and like farm nano here and like
maybe use tectonic for so we can build a farm.
Bro, I'm so, I'm dead.
I'm so dead.
I'm on May 24th.
Nice.
Coming up.
What do you see with?
Um, brick tree, brick tree.
It's tectonic.
Carra, adventure, click her venture.
Click her venture.
Marino, Fane, Marino, Fane, Marino Fane.
Marino Fane.
No, I can't do anything.
Venture's behind us!
Please!
No!
The fucking Venture Flake!
The Venture Flake!
We almost have that on a 3% off if you can live.
No!
The Venture Flake!
Bro!
Where the fuck?
Nobody fucking helped me.
No one helped me for the Venture Flake.
He said Focus the venture from no one helped me when I when
I spammed The venture flank
That's actually tilting that's actually tilting rip dokey is
1k do you see I have a solution for this
What 1k?
what 1k i don't know what you guys talking about i'm gonna
use the fucking hit now i'm negative win rate again that's
sad all right i'm gonna use the bathroom i'll be like back
chat
Select your heroes.
Yo, yo, yo, how you guys doing?
Shit!
I'm back!
It's okay!
It's okay guys, it's okay, everything's okay.
We're okay.
It's okay.
We can do this.
Just in time.
Is he gonna make a portal?
There you go.
Yay, portal!
Watch this.
Hell yeah.
Get predicted.
No, no, wow.
Oh my god, they have a junk as well.
Was this a junk from the last game?
I can't tell.
No!
Wait, the ram's anti.
You can die.
Can he?
Are you sure?
Are you sure about that?
Are you... Are you 100% about that?
Are you... Okay, nice.
He can die.
He's anti-ed again.
Good job.
I can keep doing this forever.
Okay.
I actually might have to go Kirko because they have Ana.
Oh wait, they don't!
They don't have Ana!
I can stay!
I can stay Ana!
to go Kiriko!
Oh my god.
Oh, saw a light flash by before my eyes.
Okay, well I have nano in like one game.
Holy shit.
I just built it off of...
That means they had DPL assault soon.
Because I fucking farmed this nano off of.
What?
Alright, I take those.
Okay.
Go!
Just do anything.
Just to see anything, Nano.
There you go.
I just don't miss.
It only took four hours to warm up, guys.
It just took four hours to warm up, but we're here now.
We're here.
We made it.
We fucking made it!
Aw.
Where's the pharaoh?
I was like, does he exist in my game?
Guys, I also hit those.
Let's see.
Oh, he's so dead.
He's so fucking dead.
He's so dead.
He's...
I'm not okay.
I lied.
Why did he not run out?
Alright, I guess I'll back up a little.
I guess I'll, thank you.
The junk rat helped me back up.
Oh, all right.
And we all split up.
Please.
Oh my god.
Thank you.
Oh my god, we're okay.
I told you I'll be okay.
I'm going left side.
All right.
All DPS are at different angles.
Where do we go?
I don't know.
Okay.
Which is the right side to look at, I don't know.
Oh, my HP.
There you go.
It is winnable!
I come back doom.
Oh, he's just better.
He's still winnable.
He's just better.
I told you.
We'll be fine.
I missed.
He has to die.
No, we lost our fucking...
I'm not even curious, so this is winnable.
Is it?
It didn't feel winnable for me!
Oh, wait, they flipped, they flipped.
Oh, it is winnable!
It is!
My first death, no!
I'm so...
Okay, he apologized, so it's okay.
I was like, Alan, thank you for the super chat, thank you,
thank you!
you score that's all right okay guys i bet we're gonna win
four games in a row i i can feel it i can feel it guys four
games in a row follow my lead i have more damage in the
fucking break i can fucking feel this
they also they don't have a kyrko so i they don't have the
cleanse All I have to do is just one Trigana.
No, we can do this.
First game, watching the other healer carry.
What do you mean other healer?
I'm carrying!
Doom, you went right?
Alright, nice.
Are they going?
No, they are, Doom.
Ow.
Oh, I hit something.
Cool guys, don't look at aunties.
I have you.
Keep fighting.
You have my thanks.
Oh shit, nice.
There you go.
He's also asleep!
He did not have a good time!
Holy shit!
That man got fucking bullied.
Oh my god, that poor guy!
That poor man!
That guy was not having it at all no he has an anna no it's
gonna be curicle duty soon no it's curicle time no
and a widow bro what
bro bro please have mercy
oh please don't look at me please please don't look
guys guys i have to have to play here go no it was gonna be
a happy moment I could have had I could have felt happiness
for a second
Jesus Christ.
Oh, I'm scared.
I'm so scared.
He almost has visor though
Wait, is this good?
Oh, this is not good.
This is not good.
There's no way he can die There's no way we We did it.
We did it.
We're doing it.
Okay
Now we're doing it.
All right We're doing it
Yeah, yeah, I have cleanse.
They can't do anything now Sorry, are you fucking?
Oh The fucking bait The fucking bait right there Oh, he did
Yeah, oh, the double headshot Where is she?
Where is she?
Sagger her, sagger her, sagger her Alright, there you go
Yeah, I heard about the Hanzo buff.
Please.
Not the Hanzo buff, though.
I'm tired of Hanzo buffs.
Alright, I'm helping.
I'm helping.
Okay, that hook was actually insane, though.
That was an insane hook.
Please.
We can literally kill him.
Bam!
think I saw live what an insane hook you
should pick mercy I won the game what do you mean I should
have picked mercy okay guys we're almost back guys we're at
a positive win rate I think I I could never tell anymore I
can't tell anymore you've been queuing for so long I don't
know which is positive and which wasn't i might as well make
my waiting room right now for the next stream just in case
just in case i'm gonna make my waiting room for the next
stream because it's a good night all right guys give me a
title what should the title be for my good night dragoons
number three guys what should the title be hey dokey it's my
birthday today any chance i could get a happy birthday from
the coolest thief around thank you the super chat king thank
you thank you you of course happy birthday to you happy
birthday to you happy birthday to you happy birthday to you
yeah we're not stopping until we get wait what's top 500
right now what is it a competitive leaderboard sorry this is
is on asia because i made my account where i used to live in
asia so that's a little awkward all right masters four okay
we're not stopped okay we're gonna stop at patience to keep
going i have i'm no patience to play masters for that's way
too many games to do okay well is there someone uh uh we're
not gonna get 700k yet we're not gonna get 700k subscribers
today i don't think so
thousand off.
That's way too many thousands.
One is way too many thousands.
Alright, let me see.
I'm gonna put thumbnail art here.
That's just one.
Someone had like, it wasn't post-overwatch detoxing after
Overwatch 2.
right that's good winners after party no don't say i
couldn't reach overwatch i couldn't reach masters that's not
true it's not true and i'm gonna show you guys
post-overwatch suffering i like that i like that
post-overwatch suffering um um i got mass i got masters yay
That's gonna be the title.
I got masters.
Yay.
Hey.
Oh, hey.
This guy likes...
I'll find my own path.
He likes...
He likes barbecue.
That's...
That means barbecue, right?
But see?
Barbecue...
...for maximum cooperative behavior.
That's the queue, right?
That's what it means.
Barbecue lover.
Oh, my God.
They won't even know what happened.
Yeah.
He likes barbecue, but specifically the chicken in barbecue.
That's why...
Yo, yo, yo.
How you guys doing?
No, he likes the BBC News.
I almost forgot.
He must be British.
Guys.
He must love the BBC News.
He's from British.
He's playing on any servers.
He's EU playing on NA servers.
It has to be it.
Sure.
What else could it be?
I don't understand.
If it's not the BBC News, what else could it be?
There's no other alternatives.
The BBC News is copyrighted.
It's trademarked.
Guys, all I'm saying, NBC News is trademarked, so it can't
be anything else.
Oh my god.
This fucking ham is just going a merry-go-round.
Oh.
Poor.
I think we...
I think we are...
Oh.
I missed through that.
I missed through that hard.
Goodbye.
They don't know.
They do, they do, they do, they do, they do, they do, they
do.
They didn't know that.
Oh my god, you live.
Wait, this is reconcilable.
That is a huge red.
Go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
I'm on their brig.
Huge cleanse.
I mean, it was pretty big.
This is big as BBC News.
There you go.
Oh.
We can kill Brig.
Can we?
We though.
I don't think so!
Oh shit.
Wait, we got the Diva mech though.
Okay.
Oh no.
I'm not!
Guys, I don't think... I don't think we got this, guys.
I don't think we got this.
how can your team knock that is a very good question team
how could you guys not kill her he's so dead she's so dead i
forced the fucking all right i'm just gonna tp here i'm
gonna force this and i'm gonna tp back up top and that's how
portals work I don't I don't I have to stay as main healer
because we have mercy so heal Zen is really bad with Zen is
so bad with uh mercy heals because there's not enough heals
for it so I have to play as a main healer oh I feel I'm like
thinking about maybe going on up but like I feel like I'm
just gonna get harassed as I feel like I'm gonna get like
hard like fucked over as Anna oh my god
me I'll try I'll try I can try Anna I'll try Anna and see if
I'll be okay because like looking at this I don't think my
team will save me from the trace your dive.
So I can't tell.
I mean, we'll see.
We'll see if I'll survive.
We just need a Sombra.
We literally just need a Sombra.
And then we should be fine.
Why can't the news help us now?
Aww.
Nice.
Good kill.
We can kill Ball.
Why is this?
There we go.
Guess I die.
Yes, I die.
Oh, guess I'll die again!
Guess I'll die again!
Guys, this game is rough!
This game is absolutely rough!
Let's give him his ass.
All I'm saying is that I know I'm avoiding a person here.
We gotta kill their support.
No!
I slapped him!
He lives!
He fucking lives the diva.
bomb that's absolutely fucking crazy yeah actually lose the
diva bomb
there you go i can try i did my part can you kill kiri i
don't want to get off whoa all right what a match now we
have two more minutes to hold this let's go we used almost
everything all right i'm just not very confident with the
mercy pick right now with the hammond and tracy straight on
oh and yeah oh nana full time let's go let's fucking go oh i
feel even more confident now
oh god i'm protecting you right now oh god i'll stop you
here
please mercy please mercy
oh god oh god oh i'm alive no i'm depressed guys i don't
want to stand on the cart but i will do it for gaming oh oh
god he's low please i fucking killed
What?!
No!
I just got nano too.
I live for so long on the cart because no one else wants to
go on the cart.
Why is the port on the cart duty?
Why?
The poor Anna has to be on cart duty.
The old lady.
Somebody give me a life alert.
This old lady should not be on cart duty.
Please BBC News.
Save us.
I've got a good feeling.
This could be something.
okay post overwatch relax stream there you go all right i'm
just making my waiting room right now because we have you
want to try dive okay nine p.m i assume it's at nine p.m i
don't even remember okay i'll go kiriko then this is fine
i'll find my there you go i'm pretty sure i got i'm gonna
We'll be so relaxed by then.
Why can't the BBC news help us?
I don't understand.
There's a reason why I don't want to go.
I can't.
Maybe I should care.
More on the mercy.
No, no, no, not ready.
Not ready.
Why did I decide to play fucking Kiriko?
I knew playing Kiriko was a mistake.
I knew it.
I knew it was a mistake.
The game give if and the game take it the way.
Holy shit.
We like stuffed that ball.
That ball.
ball needs to be put down in the game.
Ugh.
He's old.
He's too old.
Alright, here you go.
That body ball was really good, though.
All I'm saying is that that ball has lived past his life.
I swear to God.
Put that rodent down.
It's a pest.
Oh my god, he's so low!
Someone quick!
We literally, okay, honestly, all we need is just a Sombra.
That's literally all we need.
That's weird.
Oh, we do have a Sombra!
This is how irrelevant our Sombra was.
I didn't even know we had a Sombra.
Guys, our Sombra should not have been pushing the cart.
I'm sorry.
Sombra should not have been pushing.
He needs to be out there to get rid of this rodent
infestation.
Our cast is half his feet.
Okay.
Bye-bye.
Wait, EMP.
He- Bro, you need EMP this guy!
bro this guy is the one that needs to be please please move
move push up why oh my god why did you guys amk i literally
couldn't tp i i literally couldn't tp what is this i can't
believe it i can't believe it They're all so...
I can't believe it.
I'm gonna shake the fake bastard.
Someone get rid of this Hammond.
That's all I care.
I'll get the job done with you, Tracer.
Please.
This is for you and Kiri up there, Tracer.
Don't worry.
Don't worry, BBC News.
I'm here to help you.
By getting rid of this turret.
Oh, never mind.
Helping is over.
Thanks Oh, thank god Thank fucking god Their orb is alone on
the left and there they go Don't worry He's not buff Oh
nice, I did it I did not expect this but oh my how?
There we go we're fine We're fine We are not fine Oh God.
Oh God.
Get rid of the turrets.
Please get rid of this.
Oh!
How is the brick still alive?
We're very capable of killing the brick here.
Are we?
We're not!
Oh God, I'm not feeling... Oh nice!
Two kills!
Please, we just need to get rid of the ball.
That's all.
I care about someone please just get rid of this one thing
in my life
I have I have rush just live
okay nice not nice absolutely not nice absolutely not good
unless please please just kill the ball Please, he's just
ring around in the rosy right now.
I beg of you.
Please, he's still alive!
No!
I clapped!
Guys, I clapped!
Where's my clapped?
I gotta get off.
Stop!
Huge res!
Clap gun!
Are you gonna win this?
They don't have balls.
You're gonna win this.
Guys, I don't think they're gonna win this guys.
We don't win this.
Bro, we're like, we're super staggered.
Oh no, oh no.
Oh no.
Oh no, I'm gonna be staggered too.
JK, I'm the gamer.
Alright.
Here we go.
This is it.
Oh It's just not meant to be, you know It's just not meant
to be, you know It's just not meant to be I can feel the
tracer looking for it Oh, come on, you fucking Goodbye, this
is where I die It was nice knowing you I got you.
Wait, you can DM that?
That's crazy!
I didn't even know you can DM that!
Holy shit!
Wait, this changes everything!
Wait, that's actually insane.
I did not know that.
I'm getting on Kraser.
Right side, half HP.
That's actually insane.
Okay.
Please, it's literally Hammond again.
get in there it's really happening again oh my god that's my
i got saved my hero academia
i didn't know that why does any of the other divas ever dm
me from uh from this
oh my god okay i should go i don't think i should go defense
wise i don't like going defense actually no i should go anna
for hammond though for hammond i really hate playing um i
hate playing uh defensive uh anna on this map but like
because they have it hammond i feel like i should might as
well i feel like i should oh my god my fucking hero just one
more mission maybe if i put the spray in front of them
they'll get intimidated and stop harassing me i don't think
anyone i didn't know i don't know you can i know you can
punch deflect now or unless that was a bug because i punched
the genji deflect and and got the kill all right there you
go
all right is that we either win this or lose this horribly
we'll find out the next episode of jokey has been playing
overwatch for four hours now
well echo ball
please i can't i got knocked over we're so fucked
i'm i got knocked off so we needed help we needed help we
all needed help holy it i'll get out will i get out let's
find out i did wait are we contesting
oh no
oh maybe i should have went kierko maybe i should have went
brink but brink is not that much healing so it's i was
conflicted oh nice nice kill nice kill Anti to!
Cleans!
Trying so hard to keep you up.
Don't worry the news, I've got the news.
Retrational recall.
I'm backing up a bit.
He's at that!
He's so low!
Go, go, go!
Oh god.
My god, this is the log.
Please.
Am I breaking?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Oh my god.
Please.
I might be dead here.
Break, break, break, break, break, break.
I swear to God, I can't.
Oh, no, this is so risky.
Oh, this is...
No!
Venture, venture, venture.
Please, okay, okay, I can heal from here.
I can heal from the far.
As long as he doesn't harass me, we're fine.
Okay.
Please, the longest fight of our fucking lives.
Oh my god.
Get this fucker away from me.
Get him away!
Venture, venture, venture.
Jesus Christ!
He's won!
I'm so sad.
I'm so sad I'm actually so sad I'm so sad this hamster lived
for so long we just don't kill the healer yeah I get
harassed so much Does the MP just go for the healers?
Ignore everybody.
Oh my god.
The amount of times.
No!
Call out when you need help.
What do you got?
No!
Guys.
Guys, I think this is GGs.
I have a feeling.
Alright.
My god, I can't I can't out heal this We're just staggering
over and over There's no way we can do this in one minute
Oh, no This guy does not know how venture all works Okay, we
gotta go now get in there bridge run I'm on one Okay, that's
very unfortunate No venture, no venture.
Never mind
Bro, bro, bro, this tracer needs to get off, get off my
dick.
This is like...
Guys, it's over.
It's so over.
I never had...
Please.
Please for the love of God!
We're...
This has been the most...
It's so over game ever.
The struggle is so real.
Kill ball right now.
Oh, don't worry!
I wish!
There's no way we push it all the way here.
It's okay.
It's not okay.
Yeah, we win this easy.
Oh my god.
Bro.
I have 8k damage?
Holy shit.
It's not okay.
This is not okay.
Guys.
Guys, I don't think this is okay.
Oh my god.
Maybe...
Maybe I'll break.
Maybe?
Stay close to me and I'll keep you safe.
Maybe this is it.
Maybe all I need to do is play break as well.
yeah we can use cure yeah yeah up the win rate yeah that
that seems right guys guys maybe it's if i was brink maybe
is somber just non-stop hacks the the i'll try to peel for
you more often we have to hold a pop oh
just play what you're playing This is it.
Maybe.
Maybe this is all we do.
It should be winnable, right?
If he goes heaven.
Oh, shit!
If we could kill Brick, let's get out of...
Guys, I don't think it's winnable anymore.
There's a Brick on me behind, by the way, guys.
There we go.
I got him out.
where's that brig all right this is it this is not it guys I
think I think we know that this is not it oh my god this is
absolutely not it oh my god I'm leaving goodbye I'm leaving
oh no break on break violence let's go okay let's not go
let's not go let's absolutely not go guys it was not it all
I'm saying I was not the issue
Avoid I'm gonna avoid the mercy because I think the mercy is
the one trick And like and they don't swap so I'm gonna
avoid the mercy
And I'm also gonna avoid who was the sombra who played this
was a sombra right I assume these two are duoed guys
Reversal are you fucking kidding me?
Okay Alright, nice.
Guys, this is where our luck changes.
We're going to win five games in a row after that.
This is exactly where our luck changes.
This is it.
This is fucking it.
Bro, oh my god.
Remember that kid that was like 1k?
He actually thought that was serious?
And he, he, like, replied on Twitter asking for the actual
$1,000.
He's like, what?
What the fuck?
Bro, he actually thought we were serious about spending real
money.
He's like pulling up the re- Oh, we have a fair.
Pulling up the receipts on my Twitter and was like, bro,
where the fuck's the 1k?
Bro, there's no way.
you guys doing and by guys i mean you because there's nobody
else in vc and i'm so sad about it was like why did your
mods bad me at first off it was a timeout second off it was
i bad
say up it wasn't the mods
Who am I talking to?
Where is it though?
Oh god, I guess I'll res him.
There's a res bozeman.
Whoa.
Oh, I fucking messed up my jump.
Hey, I got you.
I got you.
I think Ruben is tired now.
Ruben is not tired.
You know how I know.
If you look at Ruben's Twitch bots, he fucking streams 18
plus hours of Overwatch every fucking day.
I know for a fact that like he's not done He literally plays
overwatch like 15 to 18 hours a day
Yeah, wait, I have all what the fuck I actually have all Oh
my god Finally Holy shit, we've actually made progress Yay
We the least dedicated that's depressing that's what happens
if like if you have you're not a variety it's the sad life
of an only FPS streamer or like only like a specialty
streamer you play the game until it dies
I'm gonna rock back to you oh I don't got you anymore oh Oh!
That fair is?
How?
Oh, he killed him!
Guys, I can't wait to get back the game, the SR I lost.
She's still grinding, not stopping until we fucking hit
masters.
It's literally- Guys, I've just been targeted, okay?
I could be masters so easily, I've just been targeted.
I swear I can easily get masters It's just streaming the
grind Is a lot more difficult They don't care Yeah yeah It's
all stream snipers guys You wouldn't understand It's just
all stream snipers See that hog put that trap there To
purposely stream sniped me He stream sniped me and then put
the trap there Fares so did
Okay, I was not saved
We saw your record before stream that's different that's
different I gained back though I'm positive I'm a positive
win rate on everything else.
I have a positive win rate on everything else, but sure go I
love having different Every single game It's my favorite You
guys just don't understand Oh Oh my god he's following me
Never go too high Okay Okay, I'm gonna wait.
I just don't want to get pushed off the map.
It's fine.
We're fine We're so fine See we're so fine
Bro, I played mercy for you Farah Where the fuck is our
We're oh Shoot the fair so I could have Oh, no, it's just a
cure code Oh, nice.
Okay.
That's good.
That was a hundred.
Yeah, it is.
It made the hog turn around and try and look for me.
So it was intentional because the hog turn around forced a
bad positioning and then let's my team, uh, it let my team
push up.
Candle didn't shoot the fair.
If he shot the fair, I could have got the Rizzo.
Oh, no.
Can I get the Rizzo?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa,
whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Go shoot the fair.
Please stop shooting the fair.
It's fine.
The Hans are alive.
Keep Hans alive.
Nice.
I told you.
Everything's fine.
I got back the SR.
I lost last game.
Yeah.
Yay!
There we go.
We're doing it.
We're fine.
Joki, when will you stop playing Overwatch?
Stop?
When's stream gonna end?
End?
Let me see what I can do.
You're never getting off this wild rives.
Look at that.
Peak mercy gameplay.
End?
How does one stop?
Look, all I'm saying is that if I wasn't streaming my
gameplay, we would have been masters.
We would have been like masters too.
Alright guys, I'm not coping.
It's the truth.
Is 100% the truth.
I'm not coping.
And?
It's because, you know, I have to entertain.
And I have to...
Oh my god.
That's fucked up.
I've never seen a more resable res.
Oh my god.
There you go.
I got it.
I got the heals.
Yeah.
Guys, I have to.
read and you know reading you know reading is not my strong
suit now imagine reading and playing the game at the no no
oh no oh no our kiriko died for her sins i don't think i
don't care can i leave this when you get hurt oh i don't
think this guy's touching oh no oh no what a nice pallet
cleanser the mercy body block right there yeah also i'm
playing mercy which i don't know you guys know this requires
a very high skill ceiling i don't know you guys know that
yeah we're back where we started guys we can do this we're
Really need to win three games in a row.
Three games.
This is where the win streak starts.
We're starting the win streak right here.
Right now.
Also, let me make my tweet for my waiting room.
Let me...
Okay.
Alright, here you go.
I need to make my waiting...
Oh, shit.
We're in game.
Alright, let's see.
Okay.
This guy was top 500 in Overwatch 1, season 1.
Damn, he's watched as hell.
Alright, Junkertown.
This is it.
Alright, now...
Now I make my waiting room tweet.
Don't worry.
I did not expect to stream this long today.
I get into these phases in gaming where...
I suddenly just...
I just can't stop playing.
Overwatch is like my biggest problem when it comes to that.
It's like when I get into like a stride, it's just so hard
to stop.
It's just so fucking hard to stop when it comes to
Overwatch.
Yo, yo, yo.
It's called addiction.
The Marvel arrival is waiting room.
Let's see.
Here you go.
No Ana.
Oh, is that a widow?
They are running widow?
I saw her crouch there.
No widow.
Oh.
Okay, I have to play Kierko Because they run God damn it
They're running on a murky So I have to play You guys see
that fucking widow right there Fear Oh my god That's fucking
right No!
Who woke him up?
Who peppered her?
that's way too fast okay I think I can drill nano here
that'll be fine he's just got hook how about Ruben I know
you can hook I know you can get that one hook that we need
okay I thought he would you know pull him to me but that's
okay oh shit alright alright it's Kirko time we are not
building our nano we're not gonna be building your nano okay
remember I say win-win our win starts now I think maybe next
game our win stream starts next game oh the mercy the mercy
successfully shielded behind you holy shit okay that was
really good not gonna lie that was a really good hook then
act good accident hook too someone please kill that we do
i'm so scared no he's so low he's so low
please we got the widow nice we got the widow we got the
widow
Okay, I got a hit though.
I got a hit.
I got a headshot like that?
That's fine.
It's not fine.
It was definitely not fine.
He's not gonna hook me.
It's so far away.
Okay, the fucking stomped, stomped, stomped was a little
scary.
Not gonna lie.
It was, it was scary.
It was like a horror film.
Scared.
Oh, nice.
We got the widow.
Oh, you're gonna wheeze.
Oh, whoa!
Not gonna peek that.
What?
Can't fucking...
Ooh.
There is no way though.
Their honor is really low bottom level.
That's good to know.
Oh, that's not good to know!
That's not good to know!
Oh, I feel a warning sign.
Wait, they...
They mercy out.
There's mercy out.
That's good.
Oh I'm okay
Fear Every time I hear those stop stop fear No, no, no, no,
I just got into oh He's not widow anymore.
Thank God I can't believe me too.
I I can't believe I lived through that.
This Ana is really good though.
Okay.
Wait.
Nope.
Missed.
Andreas, thank you for the five gifts and chips.
Thank you!
I appreciate it.
Please.
Please no anti- No!
Nice, nice, nice.
We don't care.
There's no widow, so it's okay.
Oh no.
Where are you?
I'm gonna stay up here, high ground.
Hog's coming over though.
Let's look at soldier.
You and I!
You and I, we work together!
I'll keep you alive!
You and I, soldier!
See?
Boom!
You're alive!
Magic.
Oh, that is a very good hook.
Wait, what?
Here's somebody behind us.
Oh, there he is.
Saving cleanse for aunties.
No!
Oh!
You're fine!
You're okay!
Look at that.
I'm pushing up.
I'm getting involved.
I'm pushing up too.
He'll be fine.
He has the Joe Keeper with a negative win rate on Kirko.
What's the worst that could happen?
Oh!
Alright, I can't save, like...
I can't save a bomb.
Like, he fucking exploded.
Okay.
That was like a fucking nuclear fucking bomb right there.
Basically brought on the next fallout.
Oh, he was low though.
That's what happened.
Okay.
He's giving me all charge.
It's okay.
I love all charge.
Got it?
Oh, he's so low, he's so low.
It's so low!
And he missed!
Oh!
There's no way you can die from this!
There's no way you're getting pocketed so hard!
I'm leaving!
If you die, you die!
Where?
Oh, there.
I mean, I'm fucking try my best here.
Oh, I guess I'll leave.
Oh, wait, this is last fight!
No!
This was last fight!
Alright.
Guys, why did no one tell me it was last fight?
Guys, nobody said anything.
Wait, did we touch it?
Guys, did we touch it?
Not bad, but it's fine.
Did we... Did we touch it?
Leaving in the last...
How is I supposed to know it was last fight?
How?
Why did no one tell me?
Guys, I can't remind.
Anyway, I need to do my...
I need to do my waiting room.
Okay, good night, dragons.
Dragons.
Okay, the waiting room is here.
I sure...
Time for some post-overwatch.
Overwatch last game.
Last game.
Stress relief.
Wait, the time for some post-overwatch relaxing time.
Because I totally got Masters back.
There you go.
I did it.
And is this a white raiding room?
How many seconds do I have?
20 seconds.
I can get there in 20 seconds.
There you go.
All right.
We're doing this my way.
I can get there in 20 seconds.
See?
Mercy.
Was he always mercy?
Oh no, she was like Mora.
Hey.
Why damage boost me?
I'm fucking...
Oh my god.
That's okay.
We just regrouped.
Okay.
Um, this is looking positive already.
It's looking okey-dokie right here.
Very okey-dokie right here.
Okay.
Hey, big guy.
Very fine.
I feel so healthy.
I feel so very healthy.
Bro, the Ana's just there by himself!
I think I made an error.
No, you didn't!
You don't die!
Those!
Where is this?
Where is this Weedo?
Oh, okay, wait a minute.
Oh, hog.
Okay, we're fine.
She hits those.
That's right, she is me.
Oh, never peeking again.
Never...
Never peeking again!
Just don't peek.
She is me.
I is her.
There you go.
This is exactly why I went Kiriko.
Oh no.
Oh, oh, please don't get headshot.
Please don't get headshot.
Oh, well, please both my teammates don't get headshot.
That's all I would.
No.
Yeah, I'm one too.
Why is everybody peaking that way?
widow i was okay we've got this oh my god bro you're not him
thank you all right i will
that's right you're not him swap play gangu
you'll never beat him Let's hope somebody goes down there.
Oh my god!
That's sad.
That's so sad.
Please somebody save me.
We can recontest this.
Oh my god.
I might be a liar.
Yes.
I'm definitely a liar.
The win streak starts next game.
I swear.
The win streak will start next game.
Because I don't think this game is it.
I know.
Can we kill Hog to blow?
I don't know.
Can we?
No one can hide from my sight.
Oh, whoop, whoop, whoop.
I'm so sad.
Oh my god, the very first widow kill we've ever got.
Oh, okay, he went up.
That's actually crazy.
We did it, guys.
Congratulations.
We did the bare minimum.
We actually did the bare minimum.
I'm so proud of you all.
Oh!
Missed.
Give me all charge.
Their cast is one.
Oh, nice.
Whoa.
Okay.
Oh!
I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure he was not meant.
Oh, there we go.
He hit me.
Oh, my God.
They did it.
Guys.
They used nano at least.
Guys, this team.
I'm almost back.
This team might not be it.
Goodbye.
This team was just not it.
It was just...
This team was just not it, guys.
You know.
There was nothing we could do.
It took us...
It took us 10 deaths for our widow to out-widdle the widow.
It was just that.
It really was.
not it that's not it next match surely it's the next match
is when our win street starts i believe
guys this is when our next match starts guys i think i might
need a refund on my insurance though
I think my... I might need a refund.
Yo, yo, yo, how you guys doing?
Alright, this is it.
This is when the Windstreet starts.
The Windstreet starts here.
I don't know how you...
Windstreet starts here.
This is it.
Bacon, what happened?
I thought you were paying for my insurance, Bacon.
What happened?
Bacon, did you miss out on the last month's payment?
Did you miss out?
Finding the win streak.
Oh, no.
Not a bot.
Guys, I saw you.
swear to god please please i okay got my one please i'm our
team is dead okay it's not okay okay you got two whoa don't
touch me don't touch me little bug oh
she's gonna start sucking somebody save me
Okay, we're fine Okay, no amount of money can save this I'm
sorry No, don't say that It's not me Thank you for the
Akasufa bacon It's not me, I swear
Okay Oh, shit.
Like, what the fuck am I supposed to?
Bro, I slept like 20 times!
Don't boot me in here.
Oh, God.
I will nano if it means I die.
Oh!
I said I would.
No.
No!
Why is there three people on the enemy team?
On our spawn!
Hold on.
I hooked this guy.
Look!
It's just...
Look, it's just that like my insurance ran out again.
Don't worry, I got bacon.
Bacon, like, tears in IOU bacon thinks we're paying again
for my insurance again.
Oh my gosh, he like dropped in a way I didn't think he was
gonna drop.
Oh god.
Please, please somebody kill him.
I'm okay.
Are you?
He is.
Spoiler alert, he was okay.
What's going on down there?
It's okay.
Oh god, Ruben.
Ruben, I'm scared, Ruben.
Ruben, I'm scared.
Oh my god he lives I'll punch you There you go See we did it
I have one One death
I told you it was okay Guys I told you Everything it's okay
we can do this the win streak is real this is it we just
need to win four games in a row guys guys you know i know
why i know why i haven't been winning you guys haven't been
believing in me if one person bets against me it's over so
you what is the cp so you only have So it's everybody's
fault.
No, no, I'm not saying it's your fault, Dragons.
I'm saying it's everybody's fault.
That's different.
Hey, they just gave us high ground.
This is awesome.
Guys, it's different.
Oh, no, they have Widow.
They have Widow as a fucking...
If I can make worse the dive where was the dive
I heard I want to dive widow I didn't see no dive no we
don't kill two of us How is there ever a dive?
Oh no, I fucking he's dead.
He's so dead.
I'm in a bit of a precarious situation Okay, so
boobin baited us all i saw that i'm gonna dive widow we got
baited guys
what how did he dodge that oh my god she shot himself i'm
gonna ignore the ball you guys can be okay will we i don't
know i don't feel okay I don't feel okay I really don't feel
okay I don't feel okay please somebody get rid of him you
can kill this guy look at him look at him fuck up his back
I'm gonna dive the world okay I am unbreakable there you go
damn right I got those mines
just to let you know to lock in thank you for the super chat
boy thank you for making the insurance payments for me guys
are you serious guys you're helping me make my insurance
you're helping me pay off my insurance guys i really
appreciate it it's actually crazy this insurance is like it
only lasts like one minute Oh my god, he's so low!
God damn it!
Stop!
Bro, he's actually...
He's just a nuisance.
Are you... Okay.
I give up.
Bro, leave us alone!
This is why...
Bro, Hammond's... Oh my god, he's dead.
He's fucking dead.
Bro, this is actually an infestation problem.
What the fuck is going on over there?
What is going on?
I swear it's only been the Hammond.
I swear to God.
Somebody stop this Hammond!
oh peek me please oh god guys they're moira guys i'm dead
i'm so dead guys i did it i hit my first goodbye
holy shit yes he's very annoying
all right this is it i'll nano i'll nano the soldier and
then win streak starts now
bro this happened someone please call the exterminator these
hamsters have been too much we have a hamster hamster
problem all right oh whoops whoops this is it this is it
this is it this is oh they're all running away but this
wasn't it their uh ring is the bottom right this was oh he
was but i did it Okay, he was bottom right.
We did it, guys.
Win streak starts now.
This ends now.
I told you.
Win streak starts now.
This is it, guys.
This is it.
I know you've been watching five hours of Overwatch, but
this is it.
This is it.
This is all you've been waiting for.
I told you bacon.
I told you bacon guys guys I told you guys my insurance my
insurance only lasts like per game okay
it lasts every per game guys I told you that's why that's
why that that's why we are having issues
but this is where this is where our luck changes this is
where our luck changes right here the bar stays like stay
here we go Here we go.
I believe.
Thanks for the win.
Yeah.
Shout out to Bacon, guys.
We got a huge shout out to Bacon for getting us that win.
And he said no amount of money can save this.
You are wrong.
We just need to extend the insurance.
Black, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I told you.
It's just really bad insurance like my my I got like the
cheapest one
So that's why it expires so fast Expires so fucking fast
because they only last a game each
Well, thank you for the super chatting.
Thank you.
Is diamond a good rank?
Well, it's more so of like the player base is not as big as
it used to be and because that player base is not as big as
it used to be um diamond for tank is top 500 now so so many
thank you super chat thank you thank you this insurance does
not cover any rank loss but comes with a super chat thank
you thank you thank you hat ten bucks you why why would you
better you have a gambling problem hat thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you follow this next time bro i
played paladins like a little bit i think like a couple of
weeks ago and oh my god i have bumped into team like i bump
into players with like max like not max but really high
level players who i think i was in bronze either because i
never played the game bots you can tell when somebody's a
bot or not because it has like they don't have like any like
like they actually have they have no name
wait they're all right i'll take them pet that's fucked up
that's fucked up all right there's no oh my god okay i slept
buddy oh our hanzo's fucking dead i'm fucking dead
all right okay we have faira so we have to go this oh well
this is kind of no no thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you
it's okay it's not okay for our fair it's okay there's no
way yep never mind there you go why is this happening what
have i done to deserve this it's okay oh i'm running it's
not okay it's not okay
it's five just go just go just go
Bro, I'll fucking go!
Oh, I won't go.
Bro, he's still alive!
Get her away!
Hey, guys.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Bill, thank you, Super Chat.
Make that three in the pool for gambling.
She wins this.
Thank you, Super Chat.
Thank you, thank you.
20 bucks.
You lose, win.
Lose, win.
This is fucked up.
What if I match fix this right now?
But like, I should have said that out loud.
So if I like, you know, whichever pool has the most money,
and then somehow...
Okay.
There's a line behind us.
We're okay.
Completely alone.
Without shatter.
What is he gonna do?
Kill us?
See, we're fine.
Oh my god, there's a soul.
behind us.
Kill the soldier!
Nice.
Soldier's dead.
Get this more off me!
Do it.
Okay.
Kill our...
Okay, we're fine.
We're back.
Betting your favor never seems to work, so I'm betting
against you now.
Cass, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Look at that.
E-Sports cabinet.
is now legal in 37 states.
I'm Canadian!
Wait, it's more legal.
Wait, never mind.
You're right.
Wait, it works.
Never mind.
It works because it's legal everywhere.
That's fucking right.
I forgot about that.
It's legal everywhere in Canada.
That's why streamers move to Canada.
The capo is actually true.
streamers moved to Canada to fucking gamble because it's
legal it's just so fucked up it's true it's true it was a
whole big deal no to go Kiriko all right yeah yeah you know
like those streamers that do like gambling like those
gambling streams on like not twitch was a kick or some shit
now or like i don't even know if you can do it on twitch
anymore but like it's it's because like um it's because they
have to move to canada to do it because it's legal in canada
their back is happening and they have no need okay i saved
him i'm a hero i'm a fucking hero It's bad forever on
Twitch, for real?
This is mine now.
Alright, we don't care.
Yeah, I'll take this.
Sorry, Anna.
Oh, hey, Tracer.
You know, Tracer, help me out, Tracer.
Thank you very much.
Tracer, help me out.
Oh, this is where we all die, I guess.
Whoa.
This is where we all die.
unless well, unless whoa, never mind, everybody got the suzu
except for him
hey guys, can you guys not die?
I come back at you guys?
this is bad this is bad this is bad I'm saved they're honest
that we're only down one yeah one one Take a lot of damage,
huh?
Yeah, it was definitely one.
Okay, I might have been hit.
We see daisies.
Yeah, we were definitely down one.
I dodged.
You can't fucking DM my fucking heels, though.
Oh!
Oh, my god.
Guys, I think we're gonna lose our...
I think we're gonna lose our lead.
We're so over.
We're so...
Bacon, thank you for Magenta Super!
Thank you, thank you!
Bacon!
$50 in Turkey's second win in a row.
It gotta happen.
Guys, we will start a win streak right here, right now.
We will get our fucking win streak.
I believe.
Come on, we gotta go.
We gotta go.
You and me, soldier, we have to go.
pretty good together this is it all right he has okay I need
a oh don't worry they just waste a bomb huge okay I can't
save you
please I needed you to be closer
I needed you to be closer I needed you to be closer Ruben, I
couldn't TP!
All right, we're good.
Win rate starts here.
Right here.
Right now.
We can totally kill Brigadier.
Right here.
Right now.
Please, Ruben!
Do you even know Max?
Oh, no.
Even now.
Please.
Just kill that guy.
Where's the rest of our team?
Why are they going up?
Why are they still pushing this?
After everything we did.
He's literally won.
They're trading.
Oh, god damn it.
Okay.
We're fine.
Okay, I can swap back to Ana.
I don't have to play Kiriko anymore.
Okay, I'm pushing the payload.
I'm pushing the guy.
I'm pushing him.
Here we go.
Goodbye, Ana.
Goodbye, Tracer.
Oh, there they are.
We need our tank.
I'm almost there.
Somebody.
I'm sorry, soldier.
If you die, you fucking die.
Okay, that's good.
That's good.
Ruben has all...
Oh!
It's okay.
It's not okay anymore.
It is absolutely not okay anymore.
It is...
It is absolutely not.
Just kill me.
Just kill me so I don't get staggered.
yes we just need one good fight can you be useful please oh
my god
oh my god that's actually crazy let's say oh you're fucking
welcome
We go back.
Oh, I wish we can kill a lot of things.
I'm calling out the DPS warden VC.
Oh, my God.
All I'm saying is that you guys bet against me.
All I'm saying is that I fixed this match, guys.
The match is fixed.
The spring defeat.
Guys, I got the payout.
It was because I fixed a match.
I lost intentionally.
So I got the highest payout possible.
Looks like chat is right.
The cycle continues.
Mamahaku.
Thank you.
Super chat.
I got.
I guys.
It's because.
I did that on purpose, guys.
I did that on purpose.
We're back where we were.
We're actually back where we were after five hours.
I deserve to play Mercy at that point.
I would say get another 10.
Is this how it works?
Had thinking of a super chat.
Think of it.
Exactly.
Guys.
It was all on purpose, guys.
It was all on purpose.
Look at that.
Easy.
Easiest $10 of my life.
Remarkable
Easiest $10 of my life It was fixed, guys I was here for the
big payout I was here for the big payout, guys Actually, Ray
Don't keep throwing I'm not saying I'm throwing Guys, I'm
not saying I'm throwing Guys proof you have no proof that i
i fixed the match except for me admitting that i did it
oh my god how how do we okay i'm gonna okay i'm not playing
mercy has it started yet soon soon tm soon bacon damn don't
you be losing me capital it looks like the insurance won't
be getting paid soon soon this is it oh my god at least he's
not an orb anymore like that's the best part there we go oh
what okay that's my bad where's the ryan is that the ryan
over there where the fuck is that ryan oh there he is there
we go Oh, that would be so sick if I hit those.
Alright, we're gonna go to the Sigma.
I think it's Rick.
She's winning while losing.
Thank you for the super chat, Junior.
Thank you, thank you.
That'll be fine.
I can stop whenever I want.
Guys.
I can stop playing Overwatch whenever I want, guys.
It's not an addiction.
stop whenever i want it's just i just don't want to i feel
like he has shadow who woke him
that ryan can die who woke him later
we'll find that win streak so guys we'll find it i believe
see this is it this is where oh No!
This was not it.
No, Mom.
I don't have a problem!
Okay.
I'm farming my all off this ride.
Oh my god.
Okay, we're actually throwing now.
We might actually be throwing now Ruben's rat is not known
to be like It's not known to be something that
Oh my god Who keeps it keeps waking him?
Oh God He's outside Oh I
should stop her Switch stop earthquakes!
Victoria is close.
I'm not close.
This is fine.
Sorry, I used your win streak earlier in tech.
If you didn't have it.
Bro.
Bro, do you think?
Because I don't think...
It was just insurance.
I was actually really scared.
No, Mom.
I don't have a problem.
Gladstone.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, Jordan.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Roy, I'll search the globe.
Explore the depths of the ocean.
We'll find the wind street.
Here we go.
This is it.
We're going to discover the wind street right here.
We're starting the winds right here.
Right here.
Right now.
This is it.
It's a flying car.
Oh, shit.
You're right.
No sleep.
All right.
Just gonna casually just gonna push.
Oh, he's so fucking good.
We'll be fine, right?
You're fucking- oh my god!
Okay, not gonna lie.
Guys, guys.
Guys, I'm so scared.
Can we go fast?
Oh, mercy?
That's a good question.
That's a good question!
Wow.
Well, I guess...
No?
It was the answer all along.
Oh, goodbye.
I've shot her for this fight.
Ginger, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's okay.
This is it.
Huge anti right there.
I told you that was it.
Why are they like in our spot?
Can we go run?
Holy shit!
Our heal, our DPS is like struggling.
Guys, guys I'm scared.
Kill this guy.
I'm so scared.
Yeah, shatter.
You have shatter.
100 You 100% have here What do you mean who who's gonna do
it?
Who's gonna do it?
Someone kill no, please oh there you go
It's fine We're fine.
Oh, missed that There's no way he could charge Oh Oh, why
does that hit everyone but the ride?
Why does that hit everyone but the ride?
Oh, that's huge!
I'm gonna push the cart.
I didn't see it, but it looked huge.
This is it.
I told you.
I told you a windshield would start one day.
Guys, I know it's like...
I know we've been playing Overwatch for five hours now.
I know.
But like, you know what?
But I don't have a problem
All I'm saying I just I don't have a problem
My god, I saved his life Oh my okay, that was actually a
really a really good anti Okay, our ash is so fucked I have
I think I have to go Lucio unless we touch this we might be
able to
oh he's fucking yeah I don't think he's making it I don't
think he's making it that's fine we push a pretty far it's
fine it's fine it's so fine I believe
This is it.
Prepare your defenses.
Select your hero.
I believe.
This has to be it.
You're proving me wrong.
Guess you just got loose this.
Boy, don't say that.
It'll be different.
I swear.
I swear You'll be different I'll just No, why are you on
break?
I was gonna go so yada It's not me I was climbing before Oh,
it's not me I was climbing solo too It's not
It's everybody but me.
They always say that.
They always say that because they're right.
Holy shit.
Oh, oh, that's not good.
Guys, there's a ride above.
And I'm scared!
I'm so scared!
Ana's on our high ground.
Yeah.
I got you.
I'm on my way.
I swear.
Oh no.
Oh no, I missed a nade.
And I have to reload.
I told you.
Oh!
Okay, there you go.
We're five.
Yeah, she said next team.
Not next team.
No, next.
No, you have it.
No!
Get back here!
You're going for
it!
That's fine.
Guys!
Stop!
I don't have ears!
You'll have to try harder than that.
Can we back up a little bit?
I need to recharge my shield.
I'm- please.
I'm so low.
I'm so far away.
Please.
I'm on my way.
Please, guys.
Yo, I'm backing up.
Yo, back up.
Oh, he definitely has shattered though he 100% has it he
definitely has it I feel the shatter I feel it right here oh
my god there it is there there it is there it is
What?
There it is!
All right.
We reconcast, we reconcast, 100%.
There's a lining here, though.
Oh, here we go.
Five.
Yo, what is it on to do?
Yo, what is it on to doing?
Wait, there's an Ana right here.
I'm gonna go for the soldier.
There's literally an Ana in our spawn.
Like, what?
Is there Ana still alive back there?
Where the fuck did the Ana go?
I'm, like, a bit scared about where the Ana is.
Like...
Wait, oh!
I'm defending Reds.
Wait, Ana's behind!
There's an Ana still back there?
Did we get the Ana?
Is the Ana still there?
I'm stuck.
Bro, is the Ana still...
Bro, the Ana still's there!
Bro, get the fuck away!
I...
Leave!
Leave Rachel's throwing...
Like...
They had to still...
Guys, I won.
I fucking knew it, guys.
Guys.
That's all it took, guys.
Expect... Alright, guys.
It's alright.
It's...
Oh shit, what practice range?
I don't mean practice range!
I mean, it's three minutes, it's five, it's three minutes.
Oh my god.
Alright, we're gonna chill for three minutes, guys.
A little reset.
This is it.
On the sixth hour, we're gonna get our masters here.
On the sixth hour.
Six hour.
Yeah, she got...
The enemy Ryan could not fucking heal.
Okay.
The enemy ran got fucked over because he didn't have an
honor with him.
All right.
It's fine.
Guys.
We'll be okay.
This is the win streak.
The rank up strongest bar hasn't gone up.
Guys.
It was a visual bug.
A visual bug.
You might think that the rank up bar has not gone up at all.
Like, not even once.
last five and a half hours but it was merely just a visual
bug and this is where it all changes this is exactly where
everything changes here like look at that if i can hit those
headies right here as cassidy's i can hit those headies on
my sleep dart guys this is it
right here uh blarius thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you i I can stop whenever I want chat I can stop
whenever I want guys It's just that easy I can stop here Aim
is cracked.
I know right?
I know and it translates well in game, too All right, thank
you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Keep it up dokey the marathon the win street
begins with when the better team's going to bed!
I am the better team!
I'm the better healer!
I swear!
It's just not me!
It's not me!
Guys, it's absolutely not me.
Look at those headshots I'm taking against bots!
Look at that!
Look at these flicks!
Boom, boom!
Flick, flick, flick.
Come on.
Look at that.
And then...
Come on, get an Anakin that can do that.
Go, Vio.
Like, are you trying to say these flicks?
These flicks are causing me to lose?
It's just unfortunate that every time I lose, I get a bad
player on my team.
What does each game have in common?
Not me.
I play different healers.
Because I can flex.
Like, look at that.
I haven't missed a single shot.
There we go.
I think as we're ready.
This is it.
There's no way.
Guys, there's no way.
This will 100% carry over.
100% this will carry over.
What?
I know the issue we just need a third player to play DPS so
we have all roles accounted for
all I'm saying if we have a third player we will have a DPS
player that we can count on and then I have a tank player
that I can count on and then there's me I can count on
myself
I can't count on myself, you know?
Boy, thank you for thanks.
300!
This is it.
We can do this, guys.
You have it private for friends too?
Yes, sure.
I don't think...
I don't think I'm in range.
it'll be different it'll be different we need guys i just
think we need a dps player to make this to make it work i
think that's why so funny oh my god that's hilarious i think
that is why we haven't succeeded it has to be it like what
jesus christ That was kind of a...
No!
The goal character!
Kill that guy!
What the fuck?
Okay.
Ow.
I got a little ambitious.
Okay.
The res.
They got the res off.
Bro, Sherman's been playing Overwatch every fucking day.
Beaver left us.
That is so fucked up.
How could he...
He's touching grass.
How could he?
Why?
Ew.
I've been playing six hours of Overwatch touching grass.
What the fuck is that?
Can't be any other reason.
Nope.
Oh, that was an insane hook.
Holy shit.
No sleep dart.
I'm not.
That hook was insane.
In my video game.
You see those shots?
Look at that.
And you're trying to say, I'm the problem.
Don't look at my sleep darts, though.
It says 0% sleep dart accuracy is because I haven't sleep
darted yet.
Just so you know.
room he seems to not be checking with me all right we're
five we're five missed my hook and that guy sucks dude look
i see you mercy alive because of me i'm pro here i'm gonna
hit three aunties
why would you go called it
problem i told you i wasn't the problem oh my god it was so
unfortunate that i hit that shot but then he just took too
much damage you know all i'm saying he took too much damage
we were not gonna win this anyway
content Nate is this pre-recorded it was just unfortunate
that you know the Genji took so much damage that like uh the
Genji took so much damage that like I just could out heal
the damage there you know
they're gonna use big
guys I think he's doing things guys I think he's dead got my
one it's okay it's okay it's still one more
oh god oh god we're fine oh we're so fine it's okay i got
the point though we're so fine
there you go i thought staying in the cage would keep me
safe but it didn't guys look at that 20 look at that 80
sleep dart accuracy guys look at that i'm so big you guys
don't believe me don't worry she said i mean it could be
what she said don't worry watch this your heart to keep the
scope on genomji always okay give me a sec 80 percent 80%
give me a sec oh my gosh 80 percent sleep
Oh shit, wait.
80%
Shit, guys, I'm not throwing
Guys, guys, I purposely wanted to be last To go down here
last Oh my god, 30% now Jesus, this is a lot.
This is a lot.
Thank you.
I try my best.
My goal every day when I walk out of my house.
Maybe not when I walk out of my house.
There was...
But you get what I mean.
There was a lot of things going on.
That's right.
Yeah, 80%.
It went up.
82%?
That's fucking crazy.
Okay, he is.
Yeah, I was gonna say there's no way The actual smartest
market player right there.
That's crazy.
There's no way I was gonna say
Please poop it.
I'm scared
Look I knew I hit those Thank you for it What the fuck?
Oh my god Oh, I am not good Oh, there's too many things!
Too many things on my screen!
There's too...
There's too many things going on.
Okay.
I live these though.
Alright.
Nice.
I'm at...
Oh my god, I'm at 85!
Am I at 85% now?
85!
Holy shit.
We can keep going We can keep going higher
Okay Guys Guys, our mercy's fucked.
JK, I'm gamer.
You're crazy.
Okay, I can't game anymore.
I can't game anymore.
Someone please help Ruben.
Genji definitely did not like me.
There's no way.
There's no way the Genji's gonna harass me still.
Roadhog.
There's no way we're is the genji i'm so scared
leave me alone it's okay see i told you there's no way all
right we're okay not so right yeah the genji player gets so
annoying oh he's definitely gonna have cage i feel like i
should swap the kiriko though i really want to play zignata
but we have mercy so you're not nervous learn is that you're
not supposed to play oh oh this is this is bad this is okay
this is why were they all in the cage why were they all in
the fucking cage
okay what the thing is more people ran in
they wanted to be part of the fun where's the content all
right it's time when all else fails is kierko time kierko is
always the backup this is it kierko is always the if
everything fails we go here go it's okay this that this is
our map this has to be our map right right yeah
yeah it's in five hours whoa whoa five hours it would be a
shame if we went beyond that
Oh, nice.
Go half in the high ground.
Here you want half half.
Can we get three?
Oh.
What?
Magus half.
Magus one.
He's so low.
This, what is he doing?
Okay.
It's okay.
I'm going to go up.
Oh, he's gone.
He's gone.
We're good.
We're okay.
Doki, when will we get off this ride?
Get off?
Good.
Doki.
Why are we still here, Doki?
You are here forever, remember?
You work here forever.
I'm being...
All right.
Interesting.
interesting okay the ride never ends it never ends don't
worry i have 85 we're gonna rush in we live here now
overwatch 2 24 7 marvel's rival waiting room overwatch every
day until marvel rivals come out every day until the that
game comes out the waiting room
Oh, no.
He absorbed you.
See, he's so low!
Are you fucking kidding me?
He lives those?
He actually lives those.
Holy shit.
Guys, I think I know why we're losing.
We need that deep third DPS.
That's literally the reason.
We broke out.
Broke out the cage!
Break out the cage!
Beautiful.
Okay, thank God.
Okay, we have, if we lose this, we literally have...
85 hit rare 15 code code 100 marvel wait room it's just the
waiting room that's why we're still playing guys soothing
your rooms we're still playing because we're just waiting i
i can stop anytime I want.
Chiss or one?
Oh my god, what the fuck?
Oh my god, I had to use the cleanse because I got scared.
Oh no.
No!
I got my one.
No, I still win one.
Is it actually?
Get on the point!
Get to 90!
You can do this, Ruben!
Okay.
Alright.
This is it.
We just gotta make sure they don't die.
Okay, I'm gonna protect our soldiers.
Down below our mega.
We gotta protect our soldiers.
I have to.
Here one, here one, here one, here one.
Please find our mega.
Oh my gosh.
I'll try, I'll try, I'll try, I'll try.
Big, big, big.
It's fine.
Oh!
I got you!
No!
This!
I protected the tracer!
But I don't know if it was worth it!
Oh my god.
Maybe I'll be right back when it was worth it!
Maybe we thrived the other team.
Poor Boop.
Thank you for the zoom chat.
Thank you.
It's not me!
I don't think they should.
I told you Sacrifice was worth it GT6 before a toky masters
thank you for the super chat board.
Thank you.
Thank you We broke the win loss guys.
We got win streak We got we got the win streak
The save was worth it We didn't need me we needed another
DPS we did it oh my god we fucking did it this is it this is
this is fucking it guys we broke the win-loss streak so like
it's uphill it's it's all it's all like we're all we're
still going up I told you guys I told you i told you we get
masters here not washed i'm not washed i'm gaming it's not
me it's the enemy team it's my teammates it's it's it's it
was ping they're hacking they're walling they're aimbotting
I'm getting targeted.
I'm getting harassed.
I...
Prepare your defenses.
Okay, here you go.
This is it.
Alright.
What do I play?
Let's see.
I'm getting stream sniped.
Oh, burrito.
Okay, this is it.
it's mercy time it's my turn on what you doing down low in
these ranks my turn
listen listen we're getting back up okay
there my hands are cold exactly exactly it's snowing my
hands are cold uh Oh my god, you're a turtle.
They're not excuses.
They're reasons.
Oh no.
Oh wait, that's a cool skin.
I like turtles.
Alright, here you go.
Yeah, it's everyone's butt, but me.
Because I'm perfect.
I probably get like a restraining order on you.
I'm fucking perfect.
I make the enemy team feel nothing but fear.
Alright, oh shit.
Oh, whoa.
I don't feel so good.
Wait, what the fuck?
Bro, what are you doing?
I was getting a little creative.
Why is she alive?
Yo, keep me up.
I live.
Does she?
Yo, she did not live.
Oh my god.
We, that was not living.
I think that was the opposite of living.
Dude, that monkey was one.
Definitely.
Oh, okay.
I got him arrowed!
What?
Okay, that was like the most bullshit shot I've ever seen.
Holy shit.
Look, I didn't start.
I didn't start.
I was not the first one to die, so it was not me.
That's all I'm saying.
I might swap Ana later after I get all of it.
Yeah, definitely.
Actually, I can suppose Zenyatta, actually.
I feel like Zenyatta would be perfect.
So we can burn the monkey.
All of them are under right now.
Wait, I have all...
Is your birth name actually really good?
Whoa!
No, it's just a stage name.
I was about to say, I would have built harder for you.
Yeah, it's my birth name is Jokey.
Yeah, what if it was, man?
What if it was?
Yay!
Oh.
is your birth name burrito it's fine uh kind of yeah well
don't worry we're five we gotta use this to reset he's fine
too they're all okay look at that yeah first name adoki last
name bird yeah dude those sandwiches are wicked see
everything's fine there's no mayo on a rubin sandwich i knew
we start the win streak here i'm not white What the fuck is
this?
What is this conversation?
Because you would know what type of condiments are on it
Well, I know what kind of condiments are on a Ruben sandwich
because my name is Ruben Sargazan
What the fuck is going on?
Oh shit, I got fucking shit on Let's go back.
Oh What is going on?
No ammo on there, Azaria on first point on first point
Gibraltar yeah I'm scared what is he gonna do walk up he's
walking up he's it's okay his inner demons let him be all
right we're fine see I told you we're fine he was on low
ground see I don't even think we need rush oh guys I think
we I need a rush.
Average winning team cons talking about making sandwiches.
This is it.
We're gonna be here.
You know how it's like people who celebrate?
You know what?
I bet you.
I could easily get top 500 this season.
Just not today.
Just absolutely not today Guys We will We're not doing that
today I can absolutely get top 500 I can touch top 500 I
will not end top 500 But I absolutely So fucking easy Get
there I'm not doing it today I have a life right now For
like today No,
he spent five hours for a bar to not move.
Yeah, I could be talking.
Guys, look.
All I'm saying is that it was a visual bug.
I see you.
All I'm seeing, the bug, it was a visual bug, guys.
Take those mouthfuls.
We would have, we, look, it was, I almost made it to Masters
5, but then, but then, like, um, uh, Blizzard, there was,
like, a bug in the system, and then, like, I accidentally
lost, like, 50, like, 70 SR.
It was crazy.
I was so mad, too.
Like, it, too bad, like, rewind is not on, so you have to
take my word for it.
It's too bad that, you know, You know, there was no rewind
so you guys couldn't see it, but basically what happened was
that Was that I lost 70 sr from like some weird login stuff
Oh my god, oh my god, I'm a school them actually really
close It would be more like you're supposed to like what the
fuck are they?
Make that sound with your throat in the orbs did it.
Oh, yeah, the fucking orbs I only learned the cuss words
from our Armenian homies back in the day.
It's okay.
Say it again.
Bozy Taka
It's better than the first time better than the first time
Wait fine.
It's not like this Genji's gonna chase me, right?
Are they swearing in Armenian?
I'm helping.
I help Kill bat
Oh god Kierkega Get your fucking ass out of my screen Kill
bat There you go You must kill Genshin here There we go Look
at that Windstreet Windstreet right now
Underscore Thank you for the super chat Thank you Nice I
showed told you The insurance pays off Look at that
insurance is paying off everybody i knew it i fucking
the insurance it's working three in a row unheard of this is
it this is where you're gonna hear it right now the first
the first overwatch 2 player that's gonna get a win streak
the very first one
nobody else will ever get the win streak like me
than possible
all right here you go here you go attack midtown I feel like
a zen player
This is it.
Hundreds of dollars.
Insurance finally paying off.
Thank you for the super chat.
Pagan.
Thank you.
This is it.
As long as you can hear me, it's fine.
Finally.
It only took me.
Thank God I'm on streamer mode so nobody can see me griefing
Ains.
No one will ever know.
What was it?
Aditi Vah was the one that fucked over countless people's
top 500s.
This is it.
The first ever, ever out of all players in Overwatch 2
history to have a win streak as long as mine.
Three.
Yep.
That first one.
Holy shit!
What was that?
While I was hooking, I went from a lot of HP to not a lot of
HP.
That's crazy.
Yeah, that was scary.
You won't know I'm here, right?
Okay, I got 16 damage on the board.
See, they didn't know.
Oh!
They did it!
Wow!
No!
So many friends!
Harassing our...
This is targeted!
I'll avenge you.
No.
Wait, they just used turret.
This is fine.
We got the Zario.
We can still engage and win.
Yeah, we got the Zario.
Alright.
Nice.
We did it.
Good trade.
Oh my god.
No bugs.
I can't see anything.
I can't see anything, but I think I'm shooting them
correctly.
Oh, I am!
No.
He looks rocked.
Oh, fuck.
Okay, I might have given them, like, 200 energy.
That's okay.
Oh, I got baited!
Guys, get rid of the Zarya, please.
For the love of God, get rid of the Zarya.
Oh, no.
Ruben's so dead.
He's so dead.
Okay, I gotta stop face-taking.
Oh, our Ana's so fucking good.
Oh, okay.
Okay.
Holy shit.
This is it.
That is genuinely massive as it was closing too.
Over here.
Holy fuck.
All right.
Oh no, the fucking truck fuck me over.
I'm so mad.
No, he's so low.
No!
That's not good.
It's really not good.
Bro.
Please.
Please stop targeting me, I'm just a poison yada!
And they raised their guy.
I'm just...
I'm just a poison yada!
Stop!
Huge, big kill.
Oh, shoot.
Please, Shurana.
Shurana.
I'm slow.
I have no legs.
My legs are just cosmetics.
Yo, I have a plan.
My legs are actually just cosmetic, please.
Please have mercy my plan sucks.
Oh, I'm sorry.
You were way too far Okay, we're fine There we go we got it
I It's cosmetics.
It's not real Hey, where is the castle?
me all right we're fine we're fine okay no turret no he used
my my heroes on purpose because i'm a stupid individual what
is he doing what what did he just sit still i'm scared
Oh, he was so low though.
Guys Desire doesn't know I'm here, right?
Truly not.
Oh, guy.
I'm scared.
Oh, he is above him!
No!
Oh my god.
Wait, you guys are huge.
We're doing it!
Huge!
See?
I told you.
I told you we can do this.
Yes, what?
Alright.
What kind of question is that?
We're fine.
It's like basketball.
There's like basketball!
Shoot the Anna!
I'm more important!
See?
I told you.
I think our...
Our...
Yeah, our hog is so fucking dead.
There's...
There's no way.
Oh!
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Please don't let the Zara touch me.
Oh my God, he was so low though.
Oh!
Don't let him touch me!
One bubble.
Jesus Christ, leave me the fuck alone.
Okay, at least I'll have trans for grab You won't expect me
here I'm gonna use whole heart How?
How does he know?
What?
Oh, he saw my little foot But why would he go there?
Why the fuck would he go there?
I told you I knew it.
I knew I was getting targeted.
I knew it.
There was no other reason like existing man I fucking knew
it.
Nobody believed me when I said I got targeted
There's literally no other explanation
There's no other explanation guys
How else
How else?
Yay!
I believe.
Start believing guys.
You gotta keep on believing.
is it okay I'm gonna throw a little less maybe with a Kiriko
no I think my Zen was okay my Zen was okay don't stop
believing okay maybe I'll go Kiriko maybe we need the heels
I think we need the heels I'll find my own path what was my
Kiriko win rate Like, at least 50.
To be fair, you can get a negative win rate and be top 500
now, apparently.
Please, Doki, I want to go to sleep.
Sleep?
This is not the good night, Dragoon stream.
What are you talking about?
up free us toky
don't worry i have oh good thing i went okay it's good that
i went uh it's good that i went kiriko because they went
They have Anna, so I have to go Kierko for the cleanse.
That was a hit.
It was a visual bug.
It's crazy that we're experiencing all kinds of visual bugs
right now.
It's absolutely... How unlucky are we?
Like, wow, all these visual bugs are things that hit but
didn't show up.
Like, holy shit.
How is this possible?
Wait, what the?
Bro, what?
Holy shit.
We need to call an exterminator with all these bugs you're
encountering, Togi.
I'm so sad We're so Damn, we're just that unlucky Guys, this
I'm honestly just waiting for the fucking answer Holy shit
You got it
Boom!
Cleansed Did my job I am happy.
Did my job.
It's not Dokium anymore if I'm winning.
It's reality.
I wonder if they'll expect me to do it.
Let the Kitsune guide you.
What do we have to win?
There you go.
Whoa!
Oh my god.
Oh!
Climbed.
Uh-uh.
Easy.
Reality is often disappointing.
AP, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Is Owatch a game we're playing?
If you're not a streamer, gaining income from playing it?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you.
But like, but don't play too long or you're gonna turn like
out like me with a, where a not addiction and i can quit at
any time i've got you i can quit at any time they have
fucking sigma bro they have sigma oh shit what is going on
prove it i can quit whenever i want i can't hunt i can quit
whatever i want i just chose not to quit right now guys i
can pick and choose it's just right now i chose not to i'm
escaping guys oh no we do a ministerial amount of glory i
come back on doom
all right guys i don't actually i'll be back in time i don't
what
I knew it.
Fucking math.
Math should be banished.
Fuck math.
This is why math is terrible.
We should get rid of math so we can have that.
If we get rid of math, we won't have physics.
If we get rid of physics, we won't have gravity.
Life does not need gravity.
We just want to make this game a little bit longer.
I rather we float out from the...
I float on Earth and then into space.
So then we can go to space.
Oh my god.
My fingers felt weird there.
See?
Not me.
Poor guy.
Fine.
I saved the Ana.
We're fine.
Did my job.
What the fuck?
Whoa!
I'll save you from mass!
Christ.
She just missed.
Five.
We're five.
We're so five.
Please get one kill.
What?
Oh, no.
She was so low.
She's one.
Oh, no.
He was so low.
Thank you.
Feedback, acknowledge I'll choose algorithm over.
Oh, right.
Thank you.
Guys.
Keep an eye out.
C9!
No!
Thank God!
Bro!
Holy shit!
That doesn't matter.
That provides them with nothing.
We don't get an extra fight on it.
Oh my god.
That doesn't matter.
I can quit.
Where is he?
No, I lost him!
Sorry, I missed all my shots.
Oh my god!
He fucking floated around like a fucking butterfly.
Okay.
I couldn't see where he was.
See, look, us kill us, letting them see nine that four.
Made it so that the rest of the team is staggering.
Easy.
That was so fucking easy.
Oh no.
Where is she?
Okay, we got it.
We got it.
I might be slowly losing HP, but we got it.
Oh!
And another win!
Long as win streak an Overwatch 2 player has ever got 4.
It adds up.
It keeps adding up.
I have more healing than her healing.
It keeps adding up, guys.
Wait, what?
Holy shit, that's so sad.
Yeah, it's pretty easy to get.
High healing whenever you're playing Roadhog running down.
Oh my god.
There's me.
Did you see me?
I was right there.
You see me there?
Guys, guys, we just...
Guys, guys, guys.
Remember...
We started from the bottom.
Guys.
We started from the bottom!
who you were!
Remember where you came from.
Alright.
Let's see.
What do we do?
This is my origin story.
Okay.
This is it.
You know what?
what no this is where we prove all the haters wrong this is
where we pay all we prove all the haters wrong bite size
thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you here's the
insurance for hopefully the last game i believe in donkey
thank you for the akasupa thank you thank you don't get over
no this is it I prove all the haters wrong I might have a
negative win rate on Kiriko but this is where I make it
positive wait actually like how how fucked am I this is
where we're gonna make a 35% win rate this is it
Oh my god, have confidence.
Have the confidence.
They're on Maga.
Kill me.
I get free relevant.
It's fine.
This is it.
Okay, I actually might have to go Zenyara because they have
mine.
100% confidence right here.
You've got to have the confidence.
Oh my god, he was so low.
Okay, I wanted to die there so I can play this character.
No TP.
Guys, there's a reason why I died.
I wanted to play Zenyata.
Guys, this was the strategic swap here.
I had to die so I could do this.
Big kill.
So I could do this, guys.
It was all strategic.
Oh my god, he's so low though.
He's so low though.
Someone please!
Oh that's really not good.
Oh that's not good for us.
Oh my god!
There was...
I immediately die anyway?
Woo!
This is it.
It's fine.
I got the maga, guys.
I got the maga.
Guys, I got the maga.
It's fine.
I got my one.
Oh, my God.
That was scary, though.
He has walls.
There's no way he knows I'm down here.
We already have Link Trents.
Winnebill.
We don't need him.
We don't need her.
We need me, though.
Guys, I'm just gonna slowly walk over to her.
hug guys got my one guys i told you we do not need them oh
god we could kill log out what the fuck is going on what is
going on where is my team oh my god where was my team go No!
Where did our team go?
Okay, guys.
Guys, it's not because I went...
Guys, I think...
I think...
Guys, I think me going...
Oh my god.
I think me going Kirko cursed the game.
I think it cursed the game, guys.
I think it cursed...
I think it cursed the game.
Okay.
As long as I...
Guys, I'm scared.
I'm stuck.
Guys, I'm actually stuck.
Nice.
We're...
Alright, we're gonna do this.
We go in.
We go in with that.
Alright.
If Maga alts, I'm sorry.
If he alts, I am so sorry.
Nice.
I had to.
My life was so important.
Guys, I don't know if it's noticeable, but I definitely
don't know how to position a Zenyatta.
Is it noticeable, guys?
It's not, right?
I didn't know that anyways.
Oh, my God.
Bitch.
I need backup.
Good kills.
Woo!
There is a Marga coming up to you.
I'm dead.
There are so many people there!
Guys, I don't think that one is.
Oh my god, he lost the fight?
What?
There's the enemy turret!
Guys, it was a nice- it was a pretty cool win streak though,
not gonna lie.
I think the win streak was so cool though, I was like...
Getting that win streak was pretty fucking pog.
Oh, that's where I lose!
It was- it was a cool win streak.
It was nice while it lasted, you know?
It was nobody thought we nobody thought we had it in it, but
we did
It was a pretty sick win streak for a while it really was
Why did I pull the gear go?
Here we go It's not over yet.
We pull it right here.
Well, it was the other team's one.
It really was.
Honestly.
It honestly was.
I'll find my own.
I can't believe it.
Again.
My team and also the enemy team did this to me.
As always.
They always.
do this to me yep getting some good mileage out of them no
no no this is it this is where everything changes chat
everything changes right here i think you need to spend
money in the shop so you can boost your gear go win right
shit you're right i haven't bought anything in this game for
like years that makes so much more sense
all right It's like, how else would we lose?
I didn't die though.
All I'm saying is I did not die.
To be fair, I think having a Bastion one trick is also sort
of like causing stuff.
Not gonna lie.
Having a Bastion one trick is not helping.
Oh, goodbye Bastion.
Hello!
Hello, bastion!
Don't make me use cleanse!
Oh, I should have used cleanse instead of looking at my
bastion.
Guys, I think I figured it out.
We should absolutely not help our bastion.
I think...
I think I figured it out.
We should help everybody but the bastions.
Oh, yep.
It's over.
It was so cool, though.
Having the record for the highest win streak in Overwatch
history.
A swapping four.
It's so fucking cool.
I've never experienced that before.
Okay.
Here we go.
Woo!
Okay, let's go left side
I'm okay I'm okay, or TP, so we're gonna kill her All right,
see I told you
Guys, it's not okay guys, it's not okay Hey guys, please
somebody get rid of the fucking god zone I knew it wasn't
okay.
I still have a widow up there, so don't die to her.
Well, guess who's going to die to her?
In three, two...
Oh my god, I don't have an ear anymore.
I don't...
Oh, I'm incredibly black.
Just kidding.
Oh.
Which one is ours and which one is I'll never know.
Oh, goodbye.
No.
Now we have to play this game longer?
And Maga ult?
And Larry ult?
What's going on?
Good question.
Maga.
Leave me alone.
Where is he?
Where's the Maga?
He's like up here, but I don't know if I could climb it.
Don't worry, I got you.
Wait, somebody's a sleepy...
Who shot me?
Did you hit anything, Bastion?
Judging by you being no one's dying, I assume no.
Oh my god.
It's fucking crazy.
Ah!
Someone see me!
Oh god, I just saw the fucking dragon before my eyes We're
fine Good kill on Hanso Are we able to stagger him Before
she TP's out Where is she?
No, she TPed out Yo All right We're okay We're okay We're
okay I do not have suzu We're okay They have junk Wait,
that's good They're giving up!
They're on junk right now.
That means they're giving up, right?
What else?
They're throwing!
They were not giving up, guys.
They were not giving up.
They were absolutely not.
No!
I couldn't sneak out!
out no all right just before anything happens i gotta avoid
him just just in advance oh now he swaps reaper ow it's okay
oh please get over here my all is literally right there okay
all right we're fine we're fine we're not fine but we're
still fine
It's fine.
It is not okay.
Okay.
I got you.
No!
I tanked for you!
Get a trade at least!
Wait, he did do it.
That's all I have to say.
Just say get a trade at least.
Honestly, I'm okay if we lose this, so then we don't...
I'm okay if we don't cap.
I don't think it's winnable.
oh no please someone get close to me someone get close so i
can tp please got you they definitely have tire uh i can
feel the tire coming out soon i can i can feel the tire
right now oh there it is there it is oh it's okay good job
one more minute of this here we go we're just prolonging the
invisible right here we're just prolonging this wait is the
junk rat still alive how is there someone above us or yeah
no somebody get him out of there nice okay Somebody got him
out.
This is it.
Oh, heat.
There's a mug on me?
Thank you.
Alright.
I sort of was not surprised with the outcome of that...
of that ult.
For some reason, I was definitely not surprised with what
happened there.
I will wait for Rush before I...
have rush before I uh all right here you go this is it I'm
gonna do it oh my shit all right bye okay we both use cage
and rush you're fine he's so Hello!
Please!
He's alive!
Oh my god, I'm...
Oh, alive.
Okay.
I thought I fell.
I legitimately thought I fell.
They're junk and Kiri are bottom left.
They don't have Suzu.
Okay, they're not bottom left anymore.
Okay.
It's fine, Suzu!
It's okay?
It's not okay anymore?
It's not okay?
Oh my god, it's winnable!
Okay, this is okay.
This is, this is okay.
This is this is okay.
Okay.
This is okay.
We could keep going.
It'll be fine.
I'll find my own path.
This is okay.
Dead weight gets left behind.
Whoa, is that an emote?
What the fuck?
It has to be an Emo.
What?
This is a long fucking Emo.
Does it stop when, like, he's done walking?
Oh, my God.
Wait, that's pretty sick.
I didn't know that was an Emo.
Oh, yeah.
It keeps going until...
Now push him to the door.
Okay.
Okay, come on.
It'll be cool if you walk out the door like this.
No!
It would have been so cool.
Okay, not gonna lie.
It would have been so funny if he got like headshot.
Oh my god.
What?
What happened to his HP?
Like, actually, what happened to his HP?
What the fuck happened to his HP?
Oh, it's because they have a widow.
Oh!
That's why...
Guys, now I'm not so sure anymore.
Okay, this is okay.
What?
Are you serious?
Oh, this is not okay anymore.
Guys, there might be...
I personally think they should remove Maga from the game.
This might not be as okay as I expected it to be.
This is awful.
They use them all.
It's not as okay because they have a widow.
Their widow's on fire.
Oh, no.
It's not okay anymore.
Where's our Ana?
Oh, no.
I have to do this to...
No, no!
Where did our Ana go?
Our Ana was flanking!
Our Ana was flanking so I had to heal it all by myself.
Ana, I needed heals help.
I needed you to help me.
Ana.
No.
Guys, we could have had this match in like 30 minutes ago.
Not gonna lie.
This match could have been over so long ago and I went queue
in another game.
I could have been in another game by now!
Can't believe your name is Egghouse.
It's Egghouse.
It's one shot, one kill.
It's, it's, what was the other ones?
I already forgot the other one names.
Other stream sniper mode names.
Yay!
Could have been- it was Slayer, already Tracer, it was
Kitsune, it was...
12 hooks.
Three minutes of this.
Three minutes of a perfect game.
And with my teammates, it is not going to be a perfect game
and you all know it.
I don't even want to peek.
Good kill.
Oh.
Oh, it's approaching, guys.
Oh, we're trying.
We're trying so high.
Oh.
Oh, no, I don't have suzu right now.
Oh, this is scary.
okay you have self-heal now now get your self-heal in charge
they're just waiting no oh it's okay
guys i think our bastion may or may not have been a through
like just maybe just say maybe
a reversal.
There's no way.
I got a Bastion One Trick and they gave me a reversal.
I got it.
I got a Bastion One Trick and they're giving me a reversal!
How is this fair?
It's okay, guys.
I achieved something that has never been achieved in
Overwatch history.
In Overwatch 2 history, a four-game win streak.
Guys, this has never been done before.
I got a four-game win streak, everybody.
I...
It truly was...
It truly was unstoppable.
The first one, the very first Overwatch 2 player to achieve
such a feat.
We were so close.
The four-game win streak.
streak right here live for all of us to see is that crazy
all right it's okay i avoided the bastion one trick we will
never have to deal with that it again i hope i know never
again will i have to deal with this yo yo how you guys doing
what's up man i'm doing amazingly on a win streak feeling
fantastic you ready to lose wait what absolutely not not on
my watch what okay losing is not a thing that i do no i
refuse You have to go down to go up exactly.
Duck, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Exactly.
Don't worry, I played them with the water with no ice right
now.
How's it going?
I'm in charge.
Don't forget that.
This is it.
Two games in a row.
There's no way we could fail.
Two games in a row, we could do this.
Seems more likely than you think.
Chat.
Seems more fucking likely than you think.
Attackers incoming.
Defend objective A.
They're here.
Don't threat.
I see you.
Junker queen soldier, Hanzo.
No, I'm like, what?
How did I hit nobody?
Okay, some of these...
I blame ping.
I'm going high ground.
Wait.
There's no way.
Soldier's going right side?
Oh, they're all high ground.
Oh, guy.
Oh, oh, guy.
We're fine.
Hey, there is a Kiriko over there.
MP!
Yay!
Oh, not yay.
Not yay, guys.
Not yay.
It has- been is not yay anymore i have never felt so unyade
in my life
okay i should not go marga please can i experience joy am i
allowed to experience joy and happiness it's okay um it's
okay we're killing you don't know i'm here execute him they
don't know That's the...
Guys.
I did so much.
I did it.
I actually... I actually solo killed the soldier.
Please.
The soldier.
I can't believe it.
I can't fucking believe it!
Okay, I should be able to head high ground, right?
There's no way somebody will just be like peekaboo and then
run at me.
Yep, I knew it.
I knew I'll be fine.
Are you... Oh.
He was not able to climb back up, guys.
It was...
Bad team, they're so fucking...
Where?
Oh my god.
Because you want to be...
Please.
No!
Guys.
I don't know what to do.
I'm not finished.
Why is everyone so spread out?
Why?
All right.
The use...
So I'm gonna live here now.
I live here.
This is my home.
Oh no, I have to reload.
It's okay.
I hit those.
I live here now.
It's okay.
We're fine.
Wait, they capped?
Wait, how?
When did they capped?
I didn't even notice!
I actually did not even notice the cap.
I'm dead.
JK, I'm alive.
We're so back.
I'm alive, bitch.
Okay, here we go.
I'm so scared.
I'm so...
Alright.
Fuck it.
It was worth it.
It was...
I know I could have waited for the nano for the blade.
But I can't be bothered.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Ash.
Please.
Alright.
Okay, they're gonna have Maga alt and then we're fucked.
As long as I'm not next to him, we should be fine, right?
As long as we're not next to...
They also have, not only do they have Maga alt, they also
have Blade.
But it'll be okay, right?
Not only do they have Blade, but they also have Soldier alt,
but we'll be fine, right?
Well, we'll be so fine.
Oh, this is it.
I couldn't...
Oh, goodbye.
Okay, they use Rush and Maga and Blade.
This is it.
I could...
I could see my life flash by there.
I saw it.
I saw my life flash before me right there.
exactly at that moment.
We also have nano.
Yeah, we have nano cage.
Oh no.
No!
It's because they went Malga!
I'm so close.
It was so close.
We were so close.
They still had bl- No, we had bl- This team is the anti-fun
police.
Oh my god, fuck you playing Zajana.
Dude, I hate all of you so much.
We were this close.
We were this close, everybody.
Oh my god.
I can't believe it
We were right there We were right there
This is the comeback Surely this is the comeback right
Surely this is it We'll get everything back here Genji and I
have run loads of missions like this together
Right here, right now.
No, my sanity is perfectly healthy.
My sanity.
No.
I can change heroes.
Yeah, I can't.
This is it.
Is it Maga?
Oh my god, I almost...
A headshot there.
Where is he?
Oh, he's actually so low, though.
I think it's actually not fair.
How low he was.
Oh, my God, he was...
I'm trying my best to keep him up right now.
Oh, God.
I'm just gonna stay here for now.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
whoa whoa chill chill chill chill chill chill chill chill
chill all right it's okay i discord manga it's over it's
fucking over i discord him it's so okay he got rid of my
discord but i'll discord him again and then it'll be over
what's a rush i discord him here and then it'll be over Oh
my god, he's dead.
Whoa!
Okay.
I'm trying.
Alright, he's gonna get rid of my discord.
That's five.
Nice, you got him where you wanted!
Thank god.
Where else would he want?
There you go.
That soldier still has all He's going up what's he gonna do
drop down he dropped down you're going what are you running
at where is he going
Chip never stops on and on and is beyond insane.
This is it That's okay, he's still playing manga
There you go there you go but I I'm gonna, I'm gonna die
soon.
Oh, holy shit.
I just know I live for a very long time.
None of, neither of our HP is moving.
Oh, I know for sure your HP is going down.
There's such a fun character.
I've got you in my sights.
Oh, our gangu's dead, right?
Yep.
What's behind me this entire time?
Their soldiers, Omega infant, never mind.
No, peace, bye.
Wait, what?
He has this card!
He's so loosable!
Oh, he got big...
He got big health pack.
They're about to talk.
I can farm this.
Alright.
Let's hope they do the thing.
Guys?
Oh my god.
Guys, I'm okay.
I'm so okay.
Oh!
I told you.
I told you guys I'd be okay.
Look at those dinks.
I knew it.
Go, Kirko!
Go!
You go!
You go heal!
Go, Kirko!
You better heal!
I'll put that me!
I have no legs!
I have to fucking sit here!
Oh my god, that's embarrassing.
Their bath looks like he has a window.
Oh my god.
Please.
Okay, I just wanna rush and kite this guy.
I have no idea.
I'm backing out, kite this!
okay fine i'm okay okay that's fine that's fine we do this
again oh we do this again it's okay we do this again yeah
they wasted blade as well three on all right okay everything
is not the best but we can we can just you know cope for a
little bit oh i love hearing that thing still
oh my god everybody is low i don't know who to look at
everybody is low and i'm scared
Okay, I got, uh, I got rushed before, I mean, not rushed,
cage before.
Hey, yeah, I got the way to pulse.
Yeah, I have pulse too soon.
Look, all I'm saying is...
If we have time, I'll swap to Ana.
Okay, there we go.
I need to get my fucking wall in time.
Oh, nice.
Go!
No!
Get gone!
That is so embarrassing!
I have to touch Kiri, Kiri, Kiri, Kiri, Kiri.
No!
I just got trans!
I can't believe it.
I literally just got trans.
I was like the deal breaker here.
I literally just got it too.
Oh no.
They have Mogul.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Oh, hell no.
Oh, get out, get out, get out.
Leave, leave, leave.
No, we lost our Hanjo!
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice.
That's a good kill.
They have Raj.
I'm engaged.
We have to get in there.
I have Trent!
Just make sure I live!
Oh, they have Blade, too.
Which is...
Oh, God, no.
They have Blade, guys.
Guys.
They have Blade.
So, like...
There we go.
Oh!
How is he alive?
Oh my gosh, this is bad.
This is so bad
Oh my god I kicked them off I kicked them off Oh my god That
took me kick That's the only way That was the only Wait!
Cosmetic links for the win.
The thing is...
I don't know if I should play...
I don't know if I should fucking play Anna or Zen.
Because they've both been working so well.
I will not leave a broken world behind.
I can't believe it.
I kicked him off.
Holy shit.
Nothing ventured.
Nothing gained.
This is it.
It should be it.
My mother trained half our team.
I'll sign the rest of you up for lessons.
Can I stick with Zen?
Play Zen?
Okay.
But we could build Nano!
We will find Tranquility.
But we could build Nano though.
I feel like I should play Ana for the Nano.
I'm going to go for the Nano.
The Nano for the...
The Nano for the, you know, the Genji Blade.
It might be worth it.
Just think of the plan.
This is why I went Ana.
They have no...
Oh, no.
No, the Torbjard!
Even if I was Zen, even if I was Zen, it would not have
mattered.
I'm going to say, it would not have mattered if I was Yada.
A junk rat.
Zen could have kicked the way.
It would not matter.
All I'm saying.
More dead, more dead.
After reload, after reload.
Okay.
Alright, here we go.
Zen would have kicked.
Guys, it would not have mattered if I...
I don't mind.
I almost have all two.
I'm just gonna reload just in case.
I'm a little scared knocking to that.
What is going on?
I told you!
Trust the nano!
Trust the nano.
what the same what the is happening what the fuck is
happening what the fuck okay I wish I could heal the tire
oh god oh god oh god oh
my god oh my god where is there a turret there Oh my god
There was so many things There was so many things Why were
there so many things
Okay Now the question is Zen or I'm gonna go Zen yada The
trans The trans might be clutch The trans could be Clutch
much as all I'm saying.
This could be it.
We might need this for the trans.
Amid discord.
I like the main thing.
Tranquility.
They have us coming.
So let's give it to them.
Good to see you.
Hey.
Hello.
We're almost there.
I think I think the craziest part is this might be the
longest stream I've done on this channel.
far.
I don't have a problem.
I can stop at any time.
So far, yes.
I swear I can stop.
Resident Evil was seven hours.
But don't worry.
It's not about the gaining of Elos.
It's about the friends we made all alive.
Holy shit!
Okay, he got fucking deleted!
Oh my god!
Holy shit!
Big damage.
They're on Bastion now.
Christ.
And they're on Hanso instead of Ganji.
That damage was crazy.
What friends did you make?
You guys!
Okay, someone's gonna be like, you, perilous, parasocialist.
You guys, guys.
You're my friend.
Okay, I got it.
Oh, that's okay.
Parasocial andy.
Whoa!
That's what top care.
Dink Is he still up top?
Here we go.
We're alive!
Don't keep me there so I am uncomfortable I'm killing myself
Whoa
I'm sorry, but I prefer you as a streamer.
What the fuck?
It's okay, guys!
My Discord is still on him!
I think?
We did it!
Okay.
You fucking ass.
Oh my god.
actually did it holy shit we actually did it kick the ball
boy donkey come on kick the ball point give us the content
look at me there's me you guys see me there's there i am i'm
over here do you see me i'm on the news just like bpc news
for me to beat the longest win streak oh my god It was an
expected how I'm gonna use the bathroom.
I'll be right back.
How is that an expected?
Welcome to Nujang City prepare for battle Select your hero
I'm back.
Oh, I hate this map No No Out of all the maps They have to
be this one Out of every single one of the maps It had to be
this map No And he's on Lucio Okay, this is it Guess no, the
reason why I'm playing Kiko is because I have to Because
he's on Lucio Wait, but I could play Anna Final boss, New
Junk What's wrong with it?
New Junk City is fucking terrible That's what's wrong with
it It's a terrible map I hate this map.
It's the worst map they've ever made.
If any Blizzard does watching this right now, I love every
map.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Funny storm.
This is like a little embarrassing too.
But like...
Oh.
We already lost...
Okay, I'll tell the story later.
I'm leaving you guys on the cliffhanger.
Funny story.
There you go.
That's all.
If only you'll know what the story was.
I guess you'll never know.
It's too bad you'll never know what the story was, guys.
Oh my god.
Guys, there's a juggernaut behind us!
So funny.
Okay, guys, all right, Doki, please, we can't keep a fort
paying your assures that we can meet someone.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, funny story.
I remember when this was.
I think this was, like, one or two years ago or something.
And I got invited to do, like, a testing of Overwatch 2 or
something.
I think it was like, yeah, like, like, a testing of...
Not testing.
Oh, yeah.
Sorry.
It was, like, It was some fucking in-house scrims or
something with...
With a bunch of like Overwatch content creators.
And I was like, oh cool, I didn't stream it because I was
like tired.
So then I joined it.
What I didn't realize is that devs were...
Devs were part of it.
So I didn't realize this.
And then so one of the content creators was asking for my
opinion on Overwatch 2.
And I straight up was like, I don't know, it's just
Overwatch 1.
It's just the maps are different except, like, oh, you know.
I would be like, you know, just the maps are, like, a little
different.
Like, oh, like, oh, one of the maps just is, like, nighttime
and daytime.
And then all my team was...
All my team were Overwatch...
Can we save now for H?
And then...
One of them...
I think like...
So...
Yeah, that...
That was a jokie moment right there.
It was a...
That's a manga moment.
And then...
And then I remember one of the comic creators was like,
well, obviously, like, since, you know, this guy is the
developer, maybe he could take that as...
as feedback.
And I was like, oh shit!
I was just like, oh, wait, is the desert here?
The desert, desert part of the fucking scrums?
Oh!
This is a certified dokey moment.
Very certified dokey moment, definitely.
I would have logged off and changed my name.
I should have was like, it's just Overwatch 1.
Like, I was like, that's what I said.
I was like, it's just Overwatch 1.
Like the maps are just like, oh, like there's new maps, but
it's just like daytime and nighttime.
Like...
Oh, it's me.
Can you kill their Larry?
It's me.
You weren't lying.
so yeah that was they hated toky because she told the truth
i can't believe it i got baited i got baited and seeing my
thoughts because when the conicators asked for my opinion
and then i didn't realize i didn't realize it the viewer had
gems in the team oh my god let's go
I got set up!
I got fucking set up!
Oh, this is a little awkward.
Thanks.
Whoa.
He's like one hit.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, shit.
No, don't look at that.
Nice.
Literally left him.
How are the next points in front of us?
Whoa.
There's a weedo.
Feel the weedo.
Okay, we got this.
Oh, poor Lucio.
I'm heading over to the point.
We got it.
Oh, I hear them.
Oh, he got baited.
Just like how I got baited.
the shintaga overwatch in front of devs almost the same
thing oh yeah oh yes
almost the same thing now he knows your thing the thing is
it wasn't one overwatch devs it was like two overwatch devs
on my team so
And this was when Overwatch 2 just came out.
That was like...
It gets...
I like how the more I talk about this, the worse it gets.
It was when it just came out, too.
So it was even more awkward.
Did they say anything?
I don't remember.
I was so embarrassed.
I was so embarrassed with everything that happened.
I actually don't remember.
I'm just gonna fight for a little bit later.
No!
It's okay, I need to play Kierko anyway because they went
fucking on a life flash before your ass.
That's fine.
The blackout from anxiety.
Bro blocked up memories.
You would block the memories too!
What do you mean?
Imagine...
Oh, yeah, yeah, just something similar, like, yeah, thank
you, the super chat, thank you.
I called, like, the playtesters and some of the devs and
Apex, like, bots, because I was like, I was like, oh, my
God, you guys are real play, oh, shit.
I have a plan.
Because I got invited to an Apex playtest, and then I was
just like, I was like, wait, these are real people, because,
like, I thought, like, people on my team and also, like, the
people on the enemy teams were, like, bots, like, actual,
like, bots.
And then I realized wait a minute.
They're actually like sort of communicating in text And I
was like, are you guys real p?
Oh my god, you guys are real fucking divas Yeah, I'm gonna
I'm gonna go here and then slash whoa Yeah, I go soon
though.
Oh No, it's fine.
We'll be fine.
Someone needs to touch Oh, can we touch with you?
I'm on, I'm on, I'm on.
We'll be fine.
I have to TP, but we'll be fine.
Okay.
Oh, my god.
He's going all the way over.
He's going around the world.
Around the world.
Woo!
We did it!
We fucking did it!
It's a- over we ended on new junk city while i'm telling a
story this is the game i've tried the least and we won i
can't fucking believe it's over it's fucking over geez
that's the last game for me it's actually over oh my god we
did it and so
Overthinking was the answer We did it I told you we'd be in
masters Guys I fucking told you I told no clickbait There
was no clickbait chat It actually happened I was here Oh my
god Sean thank you for the macheta soup bug Thank you thank
you Congrats we all know you can do it Now here's the
insurance for the real content to tank placements guys i'm
like i don't hate myself that much i might hate myself
enough to play seven hours of overwatch but not to the point
where i play tank um thank you the super chat thank you
thank you guys thank you the super chat thank you thank you
the head empty zatsu buff is real thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you daniel welcome to the tomato farm
welcome welcome we did it guys the insurance finally paid
off we fucking did it the insurance paid off chat i told you
bacon bacon you were there unless bacon went to sleep bacon
you were here i like to thank bacon for sponsoring my
insurance the last couple of games and also to all the other
dragoons that betted against me and tried to gamble with my
games and also to dragoons that also sponsored my insurance
as well i would like to thank them all um johnny thank you
for the super chat thank you thank you all doke had to do
was relax her yap muscles and easy win happens simple you
shout out to like rubin for playing for playing with me for
uh asking to play with me and then um and then my my actual
insurance was Ruben yeah never doubted for a second yeah
yeah sure that's fucking right yeah you totally never
doubted me at all I I definitely believe all of you um
nothing thank you thank you for the one get the chip thank
you Thank you.
Ruben, the go for playing 6 hours straight with you.
Look, Ruben streams 15 to 18 plus hours of Overwatch.
Playing 6 hours with me for him is nothing.
He solo queues 15 plus hours sometimes.
And like...
That's like different from what he does with me.
Tank, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
We don't need sleep play.
My please.
it's okay it's okay dang we have we have another stream
today in an hour and a half guys in an hour and a half we
have stream number two everybody but for now we are free
from overwatch is this actually the longest stream i've ever
done uh audio thank you for the give the chest thank you
thank you i'm gonna check this is this actually okay uh lgs
uh six this is the longest stream i've ever done this is
actually the longest stream i've ever done is of course
overwatch i'm not even tired from overwatch i honestly if i
didn't have a second stream i'd keep going but like but i
have a second stream so i'm gonna call it here everybody i
hope you guys all had a great time hanging out with me for
the overwatch section uh we still have a second stream
tonight with good night dragons uh but anyway everybody as
always everyone stay hydrated posture check get up and move
around to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me
head to you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody
or see you guys in the next second stream uh bye everyone bye